Wie es schon Tradition hat, blicken wir Anfang des Jahres mal zurück auf das Jahr im Rasenfunk. Das tun wir wie immer mit Frank, der hier mit dabei ist. Mein Name ist Max und jetzt kommt euer Intro. Das Programm der Rasenfunk.
Rasenfunk? What the hell is Rasenfunk? Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das. Das Tribünengespräch. So viel Community steckt im Rasenfunk, es ist nicht unser Intro, es ist euer Intro. Communismus at its finest, Uli Hoeneß gefällt das. Frank, schön, dass du hier bist.
Servus, Max. Heute vor allem selbstreferenzielles bla bla bla, um das Intro aufzugreifen.
Ja, inzwischen greife ich da inzwischen immer aufs selbe zurück, weil ich weiß, dass es so langsam Kultstatus genießt, dass wir hier ein bis zweimal im Jahr Wolf Fuss hören und danach dann Thomas Doll. Frank, wie geht es dir?
Gut, geht es mir. Danke schön. Dir hoffentlich auch.
Ja, du, alles gut. Wegen mir hätte die Pause jetzt noch ein bisschen länger sein können, also wir nehmen am Mittwoch den 7. Januar auf. Es geht jetzt gleich am Wochenende weiter mit der Bundesliga, gleich mit einer englischen Woche und Frank. Die DFL nimmt inzwischen gar keine Rücksicht mehr auf den Rasenfunk. Das ist echt ein Skandal. Es gibt jetzt ein Donnerstagabendspiel in der englischen Woche und am Freitagabend geht der nächste Spieltag weiter. Deswegen rate, was ich am Freitagvormittag nicht mache, eine Sendung aufnehmen, denn das ergibt da wirklich gar keinen Sinn mehr. Also dann dann streiche ich die Säge und sage, okay Leute, dann lassen wir es einfach. Ja, naja, so ist das. Schön, dich mal wieder hier mit dabei zu haben. Ich weiß, dass sich viele Hörerinnen und Hörer freuen.
Ja, ich freue mich auch. Zweimal im Jahr meine Podcast-Dosis, quasi meine mittlerweile gewohnte Podcast-Dosis.
Unser Logbuch Rasenfunk. Wir wollen ein bisschen erzählen, was wir so gemacht haben im letzten Jahr. Auch so ein bisschen was einen Ausblick geben auf das, was noch kommt. Das ist aber diesmal viel, viel weniger als im letzten Logbuch Rasenfunk. Da haben wir da ein bisschen allgemeiner drüber gesprochen. Und es gibt einen neuen Best Case, Frank. Das habe ich dir noch gar nicht erzählt. Weißt du, wer mein Best Case ist für diese Art von Sendungen inzwischen?
Nein.
Stay Forever. Habe ich wieder die letzte Folge gehört?
Du redest oft drüber, wenn wir sprechen, ja.
Aber es ist einfach unfassbar, wie die es immer schaffen, in einer Stunde mit perfekten Wortbeiträgen, mit einer perfekten Organisation ohne nachzudenken, was sie sagen, weil sie sich alles schon vorher überlegt haben oder so Gottverdammte Genies sind, dass sie es on the fly sich alles ausdenken können, schaffen die es immer einen Update zu geben. Ich liebe es. Es wird für uns immer unerreicht bleiben, weil wir viel zu gerne reden.
Und weil wir uns vor allem überhaupt nicht vorbereitet haben. Oder, naja, so ein bisschen.
Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Zehn Minuten ungefähr.
Moment, Moment, Moment. So stimmt das ja nicht. Denn wir beide saßen ja die ganzen letzten Tage schon an Dingen, die letztlich auch wegen dieser Sendung jetzt fertig sein sollten. Und das bringt uns auch schon zum ersten Thema. Denn du saßt ja vor allem die letzten nicht nur Tage, sondern Wochen an einem Thema, das jetzt in dieser Sekunde, wenn die Leute das hier hören und sehen, schon zu betrachten ist. Um was geht es da, Frank?
Genau, wir haben die Webseite ein bisschen angefasst sozusagen. Eigentlich ein Thema, das wir im November schon angepackt haben und da quasi auch schon fertig waren, aber dann kam so ein bisschen der Vorweihnachtsstress dazu. Dann waren so ein paar Abhängigkeiten da. Max musste noch ein paar Texte schreiben, ich musste noch ein paar technische Sachen anpassen. Auf jeden Fall, wir haben die Webseite ein klein bisschen verändert. Diejenigen von euch, die nicht so häufig drauf sind, werden vielleicht gar nicht so viel Veränderung feststellen. Wir haben ein klein bisschen an den Farben gedreht, die Kontraste verbessert. Wir haben die Layout-Breite ein bisschen verändert. Das war bisher ein bisschen sehr in your face sozusagen. Unser Design, unser Layout. Genau. Inhaltlich hat sich aber tatsächlich was verändert, was vor allem vielleicht für die Supporter unter euch, aber vielleicht auch für diejenigen, die drüber nachdenken, interessant ist. Wir haben nämlich die Ausgabenverteilung auf die Webseite gepackt. Das hatten wir schon lang vor. Und jetzt könnt ihr, wenn ihr im Menü oben auf Unterstützen klickt, kommt ihr auf die Seite, wo alle Infos zu finden sind, wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt. Vielen Dank, falls ihr das tut oder falls ihr auch nur drüber nachdenkt, freuen wir uns natürlich drüber. Und da gibt es jetzt eine Sektion mit so einem schönen Kuchendiagramm, wo Max ganz tolle Kategorien angelegt hat, die ein bisschen einen Einblick geben, wofür wir in diesem Fall im Jahr 2024, weil da haben wir den Jahresabschluss im Herbst für gemacht, Geld ausgegeben haben. Also wie sich das einfach verteilt prozentual.
Genau, ein Thema, das ganz wichtig, schon sehr hoch auf unserer Agenda stand. Wir haben da auch das letzte Mal und ich glaube sogar das vorletzte Mal schon drüber gesprochen, dass wir zumindest in einem groben Raben euch eben Infos darüber geben wollten, wie wir euer Geld verwenden und das war schon immer klar, hoffe ich zumindest, dass wir das jetzt nicht verprassen und wir haben da ja auch immer wieder einzelne Zahlen genannt, um eine Orientierung zu bieten, aber die Gesamtübersicht über die GmbH-Ausgaben, die hatten wir tatsächlich erst als unser Jahresabschluss feststand und auch endlich ausgearbeitet war und das hat überraschend lange gedauert, in Zukunft wird es uns nicht mehr überraschend. Also wann waren wir damit durch? September, Oktober glaube ich irgendwann. Ich glaube im Oktober kam dann letztlich das finale Dokument. Dann hatten wir endlich alle Ausgaben mit drin, weil es auch durchaus durch so manche Dinge, Schließung des Shops im Jahr 2024 plus wir hatten noch steuerliche ein paar Themen und eben weil wir als GmbH jetzt agieren, war es tatsächlich für uns nicht so leicht zu kalkulieren. Was kommen da noch für extra Kosten mit drauf, für administrative Kosten und deswegen hatten wir immer nur so vorläufige Zahlen. Jetzt sind sie endlich final und ich werde auch gleich noch mal ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Max, du aber vielleicht noch mal kurz, bevor wir gleich auf dieses Geldthema rübergehen, Max noch ein bisschen was zur Webseite sagen. Also sie ist wesentlich schneller als jetzt. Sie ist auch eben durch die neuen Kontraste und so weiter ein bisschen lesbarer. Unser Publikum altert mit uns, Frank. Wir müssen da wahrscheinlich immer mehr Rücksicht jetzt drauf nehmen. Ich weiß, dass uns ja auch ein paar Leute hören, die einen technischen Grund Hintergrund haben. Max, du mal erzählen, was hast du denn da jetzt eigentlich gemacht, dass die Seite jetzt so viel schneller geworden ist? Und was hast du all die Wochen getrieben?
Die Geschwindigkeitsverbesserung kam, glaube ich, sogar schon ein bisschen vorher, weil wir haben ja im Herbst schon mal ein größeres Update gemacht, das niemandem aufgefallen ist, weil sich optisch gar nichts verändert hat. Aber da ging es tatsächlich darum, dass wir die Software im Hintergrund aktualisiert haben, dass das ein bisschen hinterhergehangen und dabei einfach viel optimiert haben. Also da werden jetzt Seiten besser vorgerendert auf dem Server, also die liegen schon fertig da und müssen nicht erst jedes Mal aus der Datenbank geholt werden und solche Sachen. Im Grunde technische Details, aber eben schön, dass es spürbar ist an der Seite, dass es schneller ist. Google hat sich auch schon drüber gefreut, habe ich gesehen. Das heißt, das hilft uns natürlich auch ein bisschen, besser gefunden zu werden. Jetzt mit der sichtbaren Änderung, die jetzt heute früh online ging und für euch quasi in dem Moment, in dem ihr die Folge hört, online ist, hat sich tatsächlich nochmal viel optisch geändert. Wir haben, wie ich vorher schon sagte, das Layout ein bisschen schmäler gemacht, ein bisschen freundlicher, vor allem für die, die gerne den Browser im Fullscreen-Modus betreiben. Für die war es ein bisschen anstrengend, weil es einfach riesengroß wurde. Das hat sich jetzt ein bisschen verbessert. Und wirklich im Detail, also ein paar Sachen verschlankt optisch. Es ist auf den ersten Blick, glaube ich, das gleiche Design, aber eben im Detail haben wir ordentlich dran gearbeitet. Da war auch Tobi noch mal ein Stück beratend tätig. Vielen Dank an dieser Stelle, Tobi, falls du es hörst. Yes. Wissen wir sehr zu schätzen. Und wahrscheinlich wird es jetzt aber immer noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten geben, die uns Stück für Stück auffallen. Wenn euch da was auffällt, sagt uns natürlich gerne im Forum Bescheid mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder schreibt uns über das Kontaktformular, falls irgendwas für euch nicht funktioniert. Das haben wir auch in der Vergangenheit schon ein paar getan. Es gab jetzt zuletzt ein paar Probleme beim Hinzufügen von Konten für die Supporter. Das ist etwas, was ich schon zuvor gelöst hatte, jetzt bevor das neue Design online ging. Aber das sollte jetzt hoffentlich auch wieder problemlos funktionieren.
Genau, das kann man vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal erklären, weil wir das schon sehr lange nicht mehr getan haben. Wenn ihr uns supportet oder vor habt, uns zu supporten und ihr wollt zum einen wissen, ob das Geld auch angekommen ist und zum anderen eventuell auch zu denjenigen gehören, denen ich so nach dem Zufallsprinzip in einer unserer Sendungen danke, dann könnt ihr euch ein Konto anlegen bei uns, also könnt ihr euch registrieren. Letztlich hinterlasst ihr einfach nur eure E-Mail-Adresse und wenn ihr über Patreon oder Überweisung uns unterstützt, das sind allein bisher die einzigen beiden Wege, bei denen wir das unterstützen, dann hinterlasst ihr uns einfach die Info über welchen Weg das ist, also die IBAN oder eben die E-Mail-Adresse, mit der ihr bei Patreon registriert seid. Und dann ist es nämlich so, dass wir so rund einmal im Monat importieren, wir das oder gleichen wir das ab mit dem, was wir bekommen haben und dann wird das eurem Profil zugeordnet und dann eben dort angezeigt. Und da gab es kleinere Fehler, ist auch technisch nicht so trivial, weil du sehr viel Zeit da auch reingesteckt hast, das Ganze zu einem sicheren Ablauf zu machen, die Daten zu schützen und so weiter und so fort. Plus wir haben jetzt neue Wege, über die man uns unterstützen kann, die da vielleicht irgendwann auch mal eingebaut werden können. Aber alles tatsächlich nicht so trivial, wie es sich anhört. Und da gab es kleinere Probleme. Es gab einzelne User, die uns gemeldet haben. Ich habe euch unterstützt, das Geld ging eigentlich raus, aber es wird bei mir nicht angezeigt, dass eine Zahlung angekommen ist. Und das sollte jetzt aber wieder alles stimmen.
Genau. Wenn auch hier natürlich, wenn was nicht stimmt, bitte ins Kontaktformular, schreibt uns eine kurze Mail. Ich kümmere mich dann darum. Ein Punkt, der auch noch wichtig ist, wenn ihr euch registriert, dann könnt ihr eben entscheiden, will ich genannt werden oder nicht. Und ihr könnt auch den Namen auswählen, mit dem wir euch erwähnen. Das ist noch so eine Kleinigkeit. Ob wir das in Zukunft ausbauen, kann gut sein, dass wir eben, wie Max sagt, da noch andere Zahlungsmethoden integrieren, jetzt Kreditkarte oder Paypal. Aber da muss man auch sagen, dankenswerterweise. Wir haben es ja auch auf der Website stehen, jetzt auch noch ein bisschen deutlicher. Das meiste Geld kommt bei uns an, wenn ihr uns über die Überweisung unterstützt und das tun auch die Allermeisten. Weshalb es eben bei Kreditkarte und Paypal auch so ist, dass das einen kleineren Teil der Supporter betreffen würde, wenn wir das hinzufügen. Insofern liegt unser Fokus auch ein bisschen auf den Überweisungen. Das ist tatsächlich unser Hauptkanal und da hoffen wir, dass uns die Banken so schnell nicht mehr ärgern und wir die I-Bahn wieder ändern müssen. Das ist ja auch tatsächlich, wenn man so ein bisschen zurückblickt, etwas, was wir im letzten Jahr hatten.
Da werde ich auch gleich noch was zu erzählen, aber ich habe da sogar inzwischen jetzt genaue Zahlen. Das war nämlich etwas, was ich die letzten Tage gemacht habe, mich durch alle Zahlen mal wieder durchzuwühlen. 88 Prozent haben uns im Jahr 2024 über Direktüberweisung unterstützt, von euch da draußen. Und der Rest verteilt sich so 5 Prozent Patreon, 5 Prozent über PayPal und dann 2 Prozent, glaube ich, über Kreditkarte um den Dreh rum. Und im letzten Jahr, 2025, waren es sogar 89 Prozent. Also dieser Kontowechsel, dieser herbeigeführte, er konnte uns nicht in die Knie zwingen, beziehungsweise er konnte euch nicht in die Knie zwingen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr seid einfach die Besten. Denen haben wir es gezeigt. Ich sag später dann noch ein bisschen was zu dem, wie unser Jahr lief, auch in dieser Hinsicht. Jetzt aber dann vielleicht noch einmal kurz abschließend zur Webseite. Also die wichtigste Seite auf rasenfunk.de ist natürlich die des Supporter-Clubs. Die war aber eben ein bisschen überholungsbedürftig. Was ihr da jetzt findet, ist eben neben dem, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt. Und jetzt auch einem QR-Code, mit dem das ganz einfach geht, hatte jemand von euch nachgefragt. Jetzt ist er endlich da und dank Frank sieht er auch sehr schön aus. Das hätte ich mal wieder nicht hinbekommen. Neben den Wegen haben wir jetzt eben auch eine Übersicht, wofür ihr bezahlt. Und zwar zum einen haben wir da jetzt einen schicken Tracker, wie viele Folgen, Gäste und Stunden wir schon aufgenommen haben. Ich kann sagen, ohne dieses Tribünengespräch liegen wir bei 1.212 Folgen, 543 Gästen und über 2.350 Stunden Rasenfunk. Also ich glaube, ich werde immer mal wieder auf diese Seite gucken, damit ich mal die Jubiläen, die ich sonst immer verpasse, Frank. Vielleicht werde ich sie dann mal eher so im Blick haben können. Und dann kommt eben der Teil darunter, so nutzen wir deine Unterstützung. Und da findet ihr ein Torken-Diagramm, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und in dem haben wir eben unsere Ausgaben des Jahres 2024 aufgezeichnet und dann die prozentuale Verteilung, wie wir euer Geld verwendet haben. Und ich empfehle euch sehr, guckt euch das, wenn euch das interessiert, auf der Webseite selber an. Denn so im Akustischen ist es ein bisschen schwierig, es zu vermitteln. Aber ich sage euch trotzdem so grob die großen Ordnung, dass ihr es eben schon mal gehört habt. Wir haben Honorare und Gehälter. Das heißt, das sind die Gehälter von Frank und mir. Das sind die Honorare für die GastmoderatorInnen. Das waren im Jahr 2024 Eva, Nina und Mark. Und das Honorar von Moritz, der die Gästebetreuung übernimmt. Frank meldet sich.
Genau, weil an der Stelle vielleicht gleich noch erwähnenswert. Wenn ihr die Legende oder die Segmente im Kuchen anklickt, dann öffnen sich diese Legendenelemente. Und dann steht die Erklärung auch noch mal drunter. Nur falls ihr das nicht selber entdeckt. Also das, was Max jetzt erklärt, was jede Kategorie bedeutet, steht da im Grunde auch noch mal dabei. Und an der Stelle wird Max wahrscheinlich auch gleich aufklären, warum zwei Honorare vorkommen. Ich glaube, diese Frage habe ich öfter gelesen schon.
Ach Gott, das war eine schwierige Entscheidung. Wir hatten zuerst diese Honorare, also sprich Gastmoderatorinnen Moritz plus wir, mit den Gästehonoraren gemeinsam.
Und dann hat Frank gesagt, das sieht doch doof aus, wenn er hier 65 Prozent ein riesen Kuchenstück ist.
Auch wenn es nicht genau 65 Prozent sind, es wären 92 Prozent oder 52 Prozent, Entschuldigung.
Ich habe es nicht nachgedacht, aber es sah ein bisschen übertrieben, wie soll ich sagen, unspezifisch aus. Alles in einem großen Signal zu haben.
Genau. Und dann haben wir uns aber auch nicht getraut, das ganze Ding in Gehälter und Honorare zu umzubenennen, weil die Gastmoderatorinnen und auch Moritz, sie kriegen ja kein Gehalt. Das ist eben ein Honorar, was sie bekommen. Deswegen gibt es die Kategorie Honorare und Gehälter. Ihr könnt es euch grob merken, das sind eben die Dinge, die quasi bei Leuten landen, die bei der Erstellung von Sendungen nicht als Gast mit dabei sind.
Im weitesten zum Team gehören, würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Exakt, exakt. Das Rasenfunk-Team. Und dann gibt es eben noch mal die Gäste-Honorare. Und um jetzt die Zahlen noch mal zu nennen, also wir haben aufgerundet 44% des Geldes, was wir von euch bekommen haben, eben für das Rasenfunk-Team verwendet und 9% für die Gäste-Honorare. Das heißt, insgesamt landen wir da eben bei knapp etwas über der Hälfte eures Geldes, ist eben dann direkt da reingeflossen. Wir hatten Steuern und Abgaben, die wir zahlen mussten. Das sind so rund 16%, wenn ihr euch wundert. Das ist kein Einkommensteuersatz, sondern da sieht man mal, wie Unternehmen besteuert werden in Deutschland. Wir hatten noch mal 9% Ausgaben für unseren Kiosk. Das wird aber etwas sein, das 2025 dann komplett fehlt, denn wir haben den Kiosk geschlossen. Und einmalig mussten wir auch die Merchandising-Artikel, die wir noch hatten, die wir aber nicht verkaufen konnten, die mussten wir abschreiben, die mussten raus aus der Bilanz. Und dann ist eben schon ungefähr auf diesem Level, das ist ganz interessant, das hätte ich ehrlicherweise auch nicht gedacht, also die Kiosk-Kosten, die wie gesagt jetzt dann für 2025 schon nicht mehr da sind, weil es diesen Kiosk dann nicht mehr gab. Die Kiosk-Kosten, die Gästehonorare und die Kosten, die wir für Technik und Abos hatten, die wir eben abschließen mussten, um eben den Podcast zu produzieren, die sind alle ungefähr auf einem Level, nämlich 9% unserer Ausgaben insgesamt. Das fand ich ganz interessant, bin gespannt, wie sich das dann vielleicht noch in Zukunft verschiebt. Wir wollen ja gerade bei den Gästehonoraren mit der 3%igen Erhöhung pro Jahr da auch wirklich weitere Schritte gehen und dementsprechend wird auch dieses Kuchenstück größer werden. Aber hätte ich ehrlicherweise so nicht erwartet. Und wie sich unsere Technik und Abo kosten, obwohl wir da wirklich immer auf der Suche sind, nach dem günstigsten Angebot, gerade erst heute Morgen. Das war unser Vorgespräch zu dieser Sendung. Das ist schon interessant. Aber wir müssen natürlich allein die ganzen Fußball-Abus, die wir abschließen müssen, Frank. Und ich habe wieder vergessen, RTL Plus zu kündigen. Es hat mich so geärgert. Wir haben wieder 9 Euro in den Schlund geworfen im Dezember. Aber gut, jetzt ist gekündigt. Dann hatten wir noch weitere Kosten. Administrative Kosten sind so rund 6% des Geldes, das wir ausgegeben haben. Wir haben Werbungskosten jetzt aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass wir quasi Werbung für den Rasenfunk gemacht haben, sondern das meint eben zum Beispiel das Design der Webseite. Oder wir haben ja, das haben wir ja auch schon hier besprochen in den letzten Logbüchern, wir haben ja mal eine Zeit lang experimentiert mit Videos, die wir für Social Media produziert haben lassen, haben das jetzt allerdings dann auch wieder eingestellt. Da müsst ihr glaube ich in die vorletzte Folge hören, um da nochmal mehr zu erfahren. Das sind jeweils 6% und 2,6% des Geldes, das wir von euch bekommen haben. Das haben wir zurückgelegt. Das wird unser neues Festgeldkonto. Denn wir wollen anders wirtschaften als Bundesliga-Vereine. Wir wollen nicht, wenn einmal Einnahmen wegbrechen, sofort beim Staat um Hilfe rufen müssen, denn der würde uns auch nicht helfen. Das heißt, wir haben logischerweise nicht alles ausgegeben.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Wenn es euch genau interessiert, dann guckt auf die Seite und schaut euch die Legende an. Und wenn ihr Fragen dazu habt, jederzeit. Es gibt im im Forum dazu ein Thread. Ihr könnt uns natürlich auch per Mail kontaktieren. Und dann klären wir gerne alles, was euch da noch auf dem Herzen liegt.
Genau, damit können wir eigentlich das Thema Website auch abhaken, glaube ich. Und sind ja quasi schon ein bisschen in die Finanzen übergegangen.
Wir sind in die Finanzen und in den zweiten Part übergegangen, den wir jetzt einfach mal so genannt haben. Wie lief das? Ja, dann bleibe ich gleich mal beim Geld. Ich will aber dann auch schon noch mal ein bisschen was zu den Inhalten sagen. Also auch hier operieren wir natürlich gerade mit vorläufigen Zahlen, weil eben der Jahresabschluss 2025, der wird dann halt erst irgendwann im Herbst 2026 erstellt sein. Aber was jetzt schon zu sagen ist, ist wir hatten ein sehr gutes Jahr. Und diesem Jahr ist nicht anzumerken, welche Widerstände wir tatsächlich in diesem Jahr hatten. Also zum Beispiel der Kontowechsel, der sowohl uns als auch vielen von euch, wie wir wissen, wirklich Sorge bereitet hat, weil da eben in der Regel dann Einnahmen verloren gehen, der ist nicht zu spüren. Der wurde ausgeglichen tatsächlich durch Leute, die ihre Beiträge oder das, was sie uns überweisen, erhöht haben. Deswegen ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Das ist absolut fantastisch. Und wir hatten herausragend gute Monate. Ist aber so ein bisschen schwer, es zuzuordnen, woran das dann genau liegt. Also, dass wir im Dezember und Januar oft mal so einmal Überweisungen bekommen und dass der Rasenfunk-Royal-Monat stark ist. Das wussten wir schon. Aber ansonsten ist es wirklich interessant zu sehen, wie zum Beispiel auch anscheinend die Berichterstattung zur EM der Frauen da auch einige nochmal motiviert hat, was zu geben. Und definitiv auch, dass wir jetzt offensiv damit umgehen, wie wir die Gästehonorare verändern. Also, der Dezember war wieder ein ganz fantastischer Monat. Ist er traditionell immer, weil eben, wie gesagt, viele da dann nochmal einmalig dem Rasenfunk etwas überweisen. Und vielleicht steckt da auch schon ein bisschen was drin von Menschen, die erhöht haben um x% ihren Beitrag, weil wir eben ja jetzt zum 1. Januar die Gästehonorare um 3% erhöht haben. Also, vielen herzlichen Dank. Es war ein sehr, sehr gutes Jahr. Wie es genau aussieht, wissen wir dann eben erst in ein paar Monaten, wenn wir auch wieder alle, alle administrativen Kosten da noch reingerechnet haben und so weiter und so fort. Aber da können wir sehr froh sein. Der Kontowechsel und alles andere, was kam, hat uns nicht geschadet. Wir konnten es zwischendurch schon abschätzen, Frank. Aber ich denke, dich wird es auch erleichtert haben. Gerade in der aktuellen wirtschaftlichen Lage. Man hört so viele schlechte Geschichten. Man erlebt auch schlechte Geschichten, wenn man ehrlich ist. Man merkt es ja selbst, wenn man einkaufen geht, wie teuer alles geworden ist. Schön, dass der Rasenfunk steht wie ein Fels in der Brandung, oder?
Absolut. Und natürlich dank euch, liebe Supporterinnen und Supporter. Vielen Dank dafür. Ich bin auch sehr froh, dass wir jetzt diesen Schritt mit der festen Gästehonorerhöhung gegangen sind. Das hat uns ein bisschen Zeit gekostet, länger als wir es vorhatten. Aber ich glaube, das ist gut. Einerseits, weil es uns die jährliche, ich will gar nicht sagen Diskussion, wir waren uns eigentlich immer weitgehend einig, aber natürlich immer wieder zeitlich damit beschäftigen, wie viel erhöhen wir jetzt, was machen wir und so. Jetzt haben wir einen festen Betrag. Wir haben uns darauf geeinigt, dass wir das jährlich machen. Dadurch ist es ein No-Brainer. Es braucht einfach keine Zeit mehr dafür, in Anspruch genommen werden, diese Geschichte jedes Jahr abzuhandeln, sondern wir können jetzt einfach sagen, okay, jetzt drei Prozent, nächstes Jahr wieder drei Prozent. Und so ist es. Ihr könnt sicher sein, wir werden daran immer wieder erinnern, weil wir natürlich hoffen, dass ihr auch mit eurem Support entsprechend nachzieht. Aber so oder so sind wir natürlich um jede Unterstützung dankbar. Ich hoffe, das wisst ihr auch. Nur so funktioniert der Rasenfunk.
Also im Januar werdet ihr das jetzt noch öfter hören mit der Gästehonorar-Erhöhung. Da werde ich das noch ein paar Mal in Sendungen nennen. Und dann lasse ich es aber auch wieder. Wir versuchen ja und soweit ich das einschätzen kann, wisst ihr das auch zu schätzen. Wir sagen es in jeder Sendung, wie der Rasenfunk sich finanziert, weil das gehört auch mit dazu. Wir versuchen es aber auf eine möglichst wenig penetrative Art und Weise zu machen, weil wir eben nicht irgendwelchen Werbemechaniken erligen wollen, die wir sonst raushalten aus dem Rasenfunk. Bisher war auch das Feedback dazu immer ausnehmen positiv. Eher so, dass die Leute gesagt haben, mach das mal noch ein bisschen offensiver. Ich finde, so wie wir es gerade tun, dass wir eben ein paar Supporterinnen danken und dass halt dieser vorformulierte Spruch, der Rasenfunk ist, Paywall-Werbe und Sponsoren-Frei, dass der so fest steht, dass den auch Hörerinnen und Hörer schon mitsprechen können. Ich glaube, das reicht dann eigentlich schon. Und die Zahlen des letzten Jahres, die vorläufigen Zahlen, die zeigen, dass es reicht. Und die zeigen auch, dass es okay war von uns, den Mut zu haben, diese Gästehonorar-Erhöhung zu machen, obwohl der Kontowechsel bevorstand. Das wussten wir ja damals schon, dass es dann kommen würde. Und diese 3%-Erhöhung, das haben wir ja damals noch mal ein bisschen länger erklärt, klingen ja erstmal nicht nach viel. Sind es de facto ja auf Seiten der Gäste auch tatsächlich, ist es dann ja nicht so viel. Aber durch den Zinses-Zinseffekt und durch das Volumen, dadurch wird es eben für uns dann eben dann doch einiges, was wir da reinstecken. Deswegen ja, bin auch froh, dass wir das so automatisiert haben. Und freue mich total, die Beiträge werden jetzt immer krummer. Es wird immer schwieriger im Kopf, die Umsatzsteuer drauf zu rechnen, wenn die Gäste denn eine drauf haben wollen. Das sagen sie uns vorher. Aber irgendwann habe ich die Zahlen dann wieder fix im Kopf und dann kann ich die Honorar-Abrechnungen eine nach der anderen schreiben. Also es lief sehr gut auf der Einnahmenseite her vom Rasenfunk. Vielen herzlichen Dank dafür. Auch wirklich ganz toll, wie viele von euch per Überweisung unterstützen oder bei PayPal die Gebühren übernehmen. Das ist wirklich sehr gut zu sehen. Wie gesagt, 89 Prozent waren es im Jahr 2025, die per Überweisung uns unterstützt haben. Und dann lief es ja auch auf der Output-Seite, also auf dem, was ihr hören konntet vom Rasenfunk und sehen konntet vom Rasenfunk, sehr gut. Also wir haben im Jahr 2025 168 Folgen veröffentlicht. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht vergleichen mit Vorjahren, weil ich will jetzt nicht in so einen Rennen einsetzen, in welchem Jahr haben wir am meisten gemacht. Denn euer Feedback war ja und ehrlicherweise auch mein Eindruck beim Produzieren der Folgen, dass es fast ein bisschen zu viel war und wir deswegen ja an manchen Stellen jetzt schon reduzieren. Aber 168 Folgen bedeutet immer noch, dass spätestens im Schnitt jeden dritten Tag ihr eine neue Folge des Rasenfunks hattet. Und wir alle wissen ja, wie lange die in der Regel dauern. Es gab den neuen Rasenfunk Royale, der wirklich sehr gut ankam. Da müssen wir noch ein bisschen feintunen, so wie so generell der Jahresabschluss in der Bundesliga der Männer behandelt wird. Im Rasenfunk, aber das hat sehr gut funktioniert, da in der Regel zwei Sendungen pro Tag zu veröffentlichen und dann das so in einem rollenden Verfahren letztlich zu machen. Von der Organisation her nicht ganz leicht. Aber ich glaube, bei euch kam es gut an. Zumindest scheint es so gewesen zu sein. Auch die neue Berichterstattung zur EM der Frauen, die neue Turnierberichterstattung, hat ganz gut funktioniert. Da haben wir ja auch viel auf euer Feedback geachtet. Was sich da wahrscheinlich noch mal ändern wird, ist tatsächlich die Art und Weise, wann mit den Gästen aufgenommen wird. Das habe ich für mich war es trotzdem täglich fast eine Aufzeichnung. Sie war nur viel, viel kürzer und sie hatte keinen Postproduktionsstress. Deswegen war es, ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich immer so aufnehmen könnte, es wäre perfekt. Aber tatsächlich sehe ich schon das Feedback von euch ähnlich, wie es manche von euch geschrieben haben. Ein bisschen komisch, wenn man dann den Take eines Gastes hört, vier Tage nachdem er aufgenommen wurde, weil sich da eben schon Dinge geändert haben können, selbst wenn keine weiteren Spiele der besprochenen Teams stattgefunden haben. Da überlege ich mal und muss mal gucken, wie das auch abhängig von den Verfügbarkeiten der Gäste dann vielleicht in Zukunft anders ist, auch wenn ich noch nicht sagen kann, wie wir die Männer-WM dieses Jahr handhaben werden. Da haben wir uns schon den Kopf heiß gedacht, Frank und ich, und der Gedankenprozess ist noch nicht abgeschlossen und wurde auch durch externe Faktoren, die jetzt in jüngster Vergangenheit passiert sind, wegen der Zuehler und so weiter und so fort noch weiter komplizierter. Also da kann ich euch noch nicht sagen, wie wir das machen werden. Frank, ich glaube, du hast ja auch noch keine abgeschlossene Meinung zu.
Es ist absolut nicht. Und die externen Faktoren, die politischen Faktoren, wie ihr euch denken könnt, zählen da natürlich mit rein. Aber natürlich ist es trotzdem quasi das wichtige Turnier und so komplett ignorieren werden wir es auch nicht können. Also irgendeine Lösung werden wir finden dafür. Aber wir werden sehen, was es für eine ist am Ende.
Ja, also und gleichzeitig muss man auch aufpassen. Ich weiß, und das ist auch nicht komplett falsch, dass das jetzt verglichen wird zu unserer Haltung bei vergangenen Turnieren. Also 2018 in Russland haben wir berichtet, aber wir haben einen Kontext geschaffen, über die damals noch Kurzpässe mit Kathrin Scheib. 2022 Katar haben wir boykottiert. Und es ist auf der einen Seite richtig, dann daraus auch einen Anspruch an unseren Umgang mit diesem Turnier abzuleiten, weil wir uns diesen Anspruch ja selbst gegeben haben. Man darf aber nicht den Fehler machen, diese Dinge komplett gleichzusetzen miteinander, denn 2018 ist eben jetzt auch schon acht Jahre her. Und ich würde dann doch behaupten, dass sich unsere Welt und die Gemengelage ganz erheblich verändert hat und auch die Medienlandschaft verändert hat. Und man vielleicht darauf dann auch Rücksicht nehmen kann. Das heißt, wenn es jetzt nicht zu einem Komplett-Boykott käme, dann würde ich verstehen, wenn sich da Leute drüber ärgern, die das von uns erwartet hätten. Aber bitte nicht aus dem Grund, weil wir es bei Qatar auch gemacht haben, weil so direkt miteinander zu vergleichen ist schwierig. Auch wenn ich weiß, es ist eine slippery slope. Also wie gesagt, wir werden auf jeden Fall zum Kontext dieses Turniers werden wir noch mehr machen. Wir hatten ja schon das Tribünengespräch mit Jürgen Kallber. Wir werden noch ein weiteres Tribünengespräch dazu machen. Und wie dann die Spieltagsberichterstattung aussieht. Ich musste ja erstmal auch auf die ganzen Uhrzeiten der Spiele warten. Du hast das eigentlich mitbekommen, Frank. Die FIFA hat ja noch immer behauptet, es gäbe vier Anstoßzeiten für alle WM-Spiele. Weißt du, wie viele es jetzt geworden sind, als sie es jetzt terminiert haben? 15. 15 unterschiedliche Anstoßzeiten.
Ach Gott.
Es soll da schon einen Brief oder ein anderes Kommuniqué gegeben haben von Magenta, die sich ja alle Spiele gesichert haben. Andy FIFA wahrscheinlich stand da drin. WTF?
Spent ihr ein bisschen.
Wie sollen wir das denn verkaufen? Aber gut, so ist es.
Ich wollte noch ganz kurz was zum Thema Boykott sagen. Ein weiterer Punkt, glaube ich, den man beim Thema Boykott berücksichtigen sollte, ist, dass ja auch der Rasenfunk sich bewegt und verändert und auch wir als Menschen dahinter. Sprich, nur weil wir vielleicht, und ich spreche da jetzt auch nur für mich, weil ich gar nicht weiß, wir haben da nie darüber gesprochen, wie Max darüber denkt, aber nur weil wir irgendwann in der Vergangenheit entschieden haben, ein Turnier zu boykottieren, heißt ja gar nicht unbedingt, dass wir es heute vielleicht nochmal so machen würden oder auch umgekehrt. Vielleicht würden wir aus heutiger Sicht auch ein 2018er Turnier boykottieren. Das findet ja immer in einer Welt statt, die sich verändert, die sich bewegt, in der sich Dinge verändern, auch der Rasenfunk. Nicht zuletzt jetzt sind wir eine GmbH und müssen auch in geschäftlicher Hinsicht gewisse Entscheidungen natürlich mit einbeziehen und können das nicht immer nur zu unserem Privatvermögen machen und und sagen okay, weil wir jetzt als Personen so denken, muss jetzt die Firma so handeln quasi. Das spielt da alles mit rein. Also auch aus dieser Sicht glaube ich, es ist schwer Entscheidungen in der Vergangenheit zu vergleichen mit Dingen, die jetzt in der Gegenwart oder in der Zukunft passieren.
Und die Situation ist eben eine komplett andere. Ein letzter Aspekt dazu, dann haben wir dieses Minithema im Thema dann doch vielleicht abgeschlossen. Bei Qatar habe ich auch eine ganze Weile versucht dann nach dem Turnier, also ich wollte ein Jahr nach der WM, wollte ich eine Sendung dazu machen. Was hat sich denn jetzt verbessert für die Arbeitenden vor Ort? Oder eben wie schlecht ist die Situation geworden? Da haben wir aber tatsächlich die Problematik, dass es halt extrem schwierig war, GesprächspartnerInnen zu finden, die da frei darüber sprechen können. Und dennoch aber auch noch so tief im Land verwurzelt sind, dass sie glaubhafte Aussagen treffen können. Es gibt da natürlich einzelne von entsprechenden Organisationen, aber aus verschiedenen Gründen hat das so nicht geklappt. Und allein diese Situation ist jetzt natürlich bei diesem Turnier eine komplett andere. Denn die ganze Welt schaut drauf. Es sind diesmal nicht nur Teile des Erdkreises, glaube ich, so vor allem auch westliche Teile. Also gerade UK, gerade Deutschland waren da ja auch besonders kritisch. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen überkritisch, das kann sein mit Qatar. Ich glaube, jetzt durch die ganze Entwicklung auch der FIFA hat das eine andere Dimension gerade angenommen. Und man hätte auch vielleicht eine andere Möglichkeit, das mit einzubeziehen in die Turnierberichterstattung. Das wäre bei Qatar völlig ausgeschlossen gewesen. Denn selbst wenn ich vor Ort gewesen wäre, hätte ich zu den eigentlich wichtigen Menschenrechtsthemen nichts sagen können. Da muss man sich keine Illusionen machen. Da wäre sehr wenig gegangen. Aber jetzt habe ich hier schon fast schon wieder zu viel dazu gesagt. Ich bin ja immer noch selber komplett unentschlossen, was wir da machen. Aber bei den Tribünengesprächen, was ihr jetzt gerade hier hört und was ich jetzt gerade schon angesprochen habe zur WM, sind wir auch bei einer erfreulichen Sache. Neun Tribünengespräche haben wir im letzten Jahr veröffentlicht. Und klar, da waren da auch die Wie geht es dem Rasenfunk Tribünengespräche mit dabei? Aber wir hatten echt wieder ein breites Themespektrum, wie ich finde. Und ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch die, die schon länger mit dabei sind. Wir hatten immer mal so den Ansatz, 12 Tribünengespräche pro Jahr, also so grob eins pro Monat. Wir nähern uns dem an. Und ich weiß ja auch schon, was ich für 2026 jetzt schon geplant habe, zum Teil schon konkreter, zum Teil ist es nur angedacht. Aber auch da werden wieder Tribünengespräche kommen. Und das wird weiter so der breites thematisch aufgestellte Feed bei uns bleiben, der ja auch sehr beliebt ist.
Ich muss so ein bisschen lachen, weil dieses, ich würde das Tribünengespräch Paradoxon nennen am Rasenfunk, weil wir eigentlich gefühlt seit immer, seit es das Tribünengespräch gibt oder sagen wir mal so zumindest schon in den frühen Jahren erkannt haben, dass das Tribünengespräch sehr wertvoll ist für den Rasenfunk. Es sind eben Dauerbrennersendungen, wir sehen das auch heute noch, Fußballtaktik, andere Tribünengespräche sehen immer noch gute Downloadzahlen und das ist ja eigentlich was, was man will. Also klar, wir haben die Bundesliga Sendung, egal ob Männer oder Frauen, aber die sind halt nur mal nach zwei Wochen nicht mehr interessant so wirklich. Die hört niemand oder nur ganz wenige hören die in weiter zurück nachträglich. Aber die Tribünengespräche oder auch alte Kurzpässe und so zu besonderen Themen sind einfach immer noch länger interessant. Und trotzdem ist es auch schon gefühlt seit immer so, dass wir uns darüber ärgern, dass so wenig Zeit bleibt für mehr Tribünengespräche, weil es wären eigentlich auch so viele Ideen da. Und also die Liste ist lang, können wir versichern, glaube ich, und die ist schon immer lang. Und es gibt schon lange dieses Vorhaben, 12 pro Jahr, also eins pro Monat. Und selten sind wir aber so nahe rangekommen wie dieses Jahr. Also tatsächlich kann man es positiv sehen, aber es ist trotzdem auch eben dieses Phänomen, dass es eigentlich auch immer zu wenig Tribünengespräche sind. Aber es passt halt einfach zeitlich, weil sie natürlich auch zeitaufwendig sind in der Recherche und so. Da versuchen wir auch gerade ein paar Dinge zu verändern, zu verbessern, ein bisschen auszuloten, inwieweit KI da ein Thema für uns sein kann. Da basteln wir und versuchen im Hintergrund. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es immer noch viel Arbeit und viel Zeit. Und Max hatte eigentlich auch schon Ideen, noch mehr Zeit in die Produktion zu stecken. Und na ja, wie es halt eben so ist. Aber das bringt mich eben immer wieder zum schmunzeln, weil es in jedem Logbuch wieder dasselbe ist, wenn wir über Tribünengespräche sprechen.
Vielleicht muss ich es einfach mal öffentlich aussprechen. Vielleicht fällt es mir dann leichter, mich auch dran zu halten. Es braucht mehr Mut zur Lücke meinerseits bei Tribünengesprächen. Ich muss nicht immer alles zu einem Thema wissen, bevor ich in ein Tribünengespräch gehe. Vielleicht kann ich es mal wagen, einfach mal so wie andere Podcasts, dass sie auch machen, einfach ein Gespräch über ein Thema zu führen und es auszuhalten, dass man es nicht zu Ende erzählt hat in einer Sendung. Ich probiere es. Ich nehme es mir jetzt hiermit auch öffentlich vor und aber zu dem anderen Thema noch eben die Vorbereitung von Tribünengesprächen. Das Tribünengespräch Geschichte des Fußballs in den USA. Das wäre ohne deine Mithilfe und die Mithilfe von in dem Fall sehr schlauer KI so nicht möglich gewesen. Das muss man wirklich einfach sagen.
Das hat einfach ein bisschen Zeit gespart.
Ja, ein bisschen Zeit würde ich mal sagen, eine Woche ungefähr. Weil trotzdem da noch drei sehr intensive Tage Vorbereitung. Aber das hätte ich ohne diesen ganzen Input anders nicht hinbekommen. Also wir haben viele Sendungen veröffentlicht. Wir hatten dabei eine Quote an weiblichen Gästen von 34 Prozent. Vielen Dank an Zaunpfahl, der das mal wieder ausgerechnet hat. 34 Prozent ist entfernt, ein ganzes Stück entfernt von dem, was wir gerne hätten. Wir hätten natürlich gerne ein 50-50-Verhältnis zwischen Frauen und Männern als Gästen. Also es geht jetzt nur um die Gäste. Es geht um die Moderierenden, haben wir da rausgerechnet. Dann wäre die Quote natürlich noch schlechter. Ihr kennt die Thematik, ihr wisst, dass sie uns am Herzen liegt. Ihr kennt auch die Problematik, warum es nicht so einfach zu erreichen ist. Und dennoch lasse ich mir eben immer wieder jedes Jahr von Zaunpfahl diese Zahl ausrechnen, weil ich mich an ihr messen lassen will und weil ich mich dann auch darüber ärgere, dass das Gefühl, das ich schon hatte, es ist leicht zurückgegangen, dass wir die weiblichen Gäste im Rasenfunk, der Anteil der weiblichen Gäste, des Rasenfunks, dieses Gefühl ist jetzt mit einer Zahl untermauert. Jetzt habe ich eine Zahl, an der ich mich messen lassen werde in diesem Jahr und mal gucken, ob wir dahingehend noch was tun können. Riesiges Thema, aber ich wollte es hier eben auch nicht verschweigen, auch wenn es natürlich 34 Prozent immer noch nicht gut genug ist. Dann haben wir die Ligatour in der zweiten Liga jetzt komplett in die Hände von Yvonne Maag gegeben, kam sehr gut an und funktioniert auch für uns sehr gut. Und wir haben, wie immer, sehr viel Feedback bekommen. Also allein im Forum waren es 10.500 Beiträge, so grob. Im letzten Jahr bei YouTube nochmal 5.000 Kommentare. Andere Plattformen konnte ich nicht so gut auszählen. Also bei Instagram und Blue Sky ist sicherlich noch einiges reingekommen. Fast alles davon habe ich gelesen. Zeigt auch mal wieder, wo viel meiner Zeit hingegangen ist im letzten Jahr. Aber der Output war wieder wirklich sehr groß beim Rasenfunk. Der Input von euch aber auch. Und beides bildet ja letztlich den Rasenfunk. Das heißt, nicht nur war es finanziell ein gutes Jahr, sondern inhaltlich finde ich auch mit Höhen und Tiefen natürlich. Und mit ärgerlichen Fehlern, die hin und wieder leider immer wieder passieren, war es aber dennoch ein gutes Rasenfunk-Jahr. Und so wurde es uns ja auch von euch gespiegelt, dass ihr zufrieden wart mit den Sendungen.
Absolut, vielen Dank für eure Beteiligung.
Aber wirklich.
Vor allem im Forum, ich finde es klasse, wie sich das entwickelt. Und wie das Forum auch, wenn auch nicht immer ganz von selbst, gab es ja auch ein paar Moderationseingriffe, die nötig waren. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, ich kenne Communities nun seit 25 Jahren grob im Internet, in allen Formen und Farben. Und da muss man schon sagen, die Rasenfunks-Community ist, glaube ich, die stressfreieste, die man sich wünschen kann insgesamt. Und die einzelnen Ausreißer sind halt leider trotzdem da, aber im Gesamten kann man, glaube ich, sagen, regelt sich vieles von selbst. Und das ist sehr schön.
Das stimmt. Es war jetzt so, dass wir im letzten Jahr zum ersten Mal einen Nutzer für immer sperren mussten. Also er war schon mal kurz gesperrt, kam dann wieder, hat direkt so weitergemacht wie vier Wochen vorher. Und nach einer dann sehr deutlichen Ansage meinerseits war dann klar, okay, gut, das war es jetzt mit ihm in diesem Forum. Das ist sehr schade. Allerdings weiß ich ja auch noch aus meiner Zeit als Community Manager bei Neon und bei Spox, dass das ab einer gewissen Größe eines Forums passiert. Und wir haben das weiter im Blick. Es gibt manchmal noch so ein bisschen das Problem, dass so ein Forum immer von einem kleinen Kerl, einem kleinen Kern an Menschen lebt, die jeden Tag und manchmal sogar stündlich im Forum unterwegs sind. Und dann gibt es so eine Peripherie von Leuten, die legen sich einen Account an und schreiben ein bis zwei Mal pro Jahr, wenn es ihnen wichtig ist. Und es gibt die Neuankömmliche, die völlig unbedarft in dieses Forum rein stolpern und dann manchmal innerhalb weniger Minuten schon wieder weg sind, weil tatsächlich die Willkommenskultur in so einem Forum wirklich entscheidend ist. Aber die wird geprägt vom harten Kern der Leute, die oft miteinander diskutieren, manchmal auch ausschweifend über Themen, die gar nicht mehr mit dem zu tun haben, worum es eigentlich in dem Ursprungsthread ging. Da habe ich ja schon jetzt manchmal eingegriffen im letzten Jahr und nehme auch eine deutliche Verbesserung war. Aber ich glaube, dass manchmal die Menschen, die da miteinander diskutieren, die auch, weil sie sich kennen, dann vielleicht auch schon so eine Tonalität untereinander haben, die sie jeweils verstehen, die aber auf andere ein bisschen ruppig wirken kann oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen arg ironisch manchmal. Ich glaube, manchmal sieht dieser Kern im Forum nicht, dass man damit den Neuankömmlingen, schon bevor sie den ersten Kommentar geschrieben haben letztlich oder sich registriert haben, so ein Hindernis gesetzt hat, sich einzulassen auf diese Community. In der perfekten Welt werden wir da noch ein bisschen uns dessen bewusster. Ich will jetzt aber auch nicht diejenigen Leute zu hart kritisieren, die letztlich den Kern des Forums ausmachen. Ich weiß, dass sowas automatisch passiert und ich habe es ja auch schon thematisiert im direkten Gespräch mit einigen von ihnen und auch mal so mit öffentlichen Posts, die ich geschrieben habe. Es ist immer noch eine sehr nette Plattform und ich kann alle nur ermuntern. Schaut mal ins Forum mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, macht sehr gerne mit. Gerade auf Input-Seite für die Sendung finde ich es extrem wertvoll. Und auch um so ein bisschen mitzubekommen, wie die Fans gerade ticken, weil ich brauche jetzt nicht auf Facebook zu gucken und zu wissen zu wollen, wie VfB-Fans gerade so drauf sind. Da ist es mir schon lieber bei uns im Forum, denn da landet schon einfach eine gewisse Art von... Warum nur? Ja, weil ich weiß es jetzt auch nicht. Es tut mir auch leid, dass ich jetzt schon wieder in VfB als Beispiel genommen habe. Aber ja, aber es ist halt gerade VfB und Eintracht Frankfurt. Da sitzt gerade der Caps Lock, die Feststelltaste, die sitzt fest bei vielen von denen. Muss man leider einfach so sagen. Das war, wie das Jahr lief. Wir haben noch den kleinen Punkt, Änderungen zum neuen Jahr. Das ist aber wirklich ein kleiner Punkt, denn so richtig konkret gibt es da nichts, was wir euch jetzt schon sagen könnten. Wir haben jetzt hier schon ein bisschen vorgezogen, die Diskussion, wie werden wir mit der Weltmeisterschaft der Männer umgehen. Das ist noch nicht entschieden. Das wird sich zeigen. Es wird keine großen Änderungen an den Formaten geben. Wir finden, dass die Umstellung, die wir da gemacht haben, sehr gut funktioniert hat. Also spricht der Rasenfunk Royale, erscheint wieder in den Einzelepisoden. Das mit den Schwerpunkten bei der Bundesliga der Männer, dass es weniger sind und auch nicht mehr zwanghaft je einer, je Verein, je Hin- und Rückrunde. Das ziehen wir jetzt natürlich auch bis Ende des Jahres durch und ziehen dann Bilanz. Ich weiß, dass es da auch schon viele Gefühle und Meinungen von euch dazu jetzt schon gibt, vor allem von den Fans derjenigen Teams, die noch nicht dran waren. Lasst uns da nach der Saison, auch nach dem Royal noch mal draufblicken und das Ganze als Gesamtes betrachten. Also es wird ja dann, zumindest ist das schon der Plan, von jedem Verein einen Fokus Schwerpunkt gegeben haben, irgendwann in der Saison plus das Saisonabschlussgespräch. Das nenne ich jetzt mal, bei dem ich auch nicht mehr auf die Zeit geguckt habe, also wo ich den Gästen nicht mehr nach 45 Minuten versucht habe, sie so auf die Straße zur Abmoderation zu bringen, sondern wo ich gesagt habe, okay gut, das ist jetzt hier im Zweifel nur ich, der hier in terminliche Probleme mit anderen Aufnahmen kommt. Machen wir eben eine Stunde 15, machen wir eine Stunde 30. Lasst uns danach dann mal draufblicken, wie wir das alles so finden, wie glücklich wir damit sind und dann schauen wir weiter. Und Ligatur wird auch erst mal weiter so laufen. Die Europasendung mache ich und zweite Liga der Männer, Mark und Eva und alle Input-Fragen von euch hinsichtlich. Macht doch auch bei den Frauen Schwerpunkte, macht auch bei den Frauen Royal oder macht doch auch dritte Liga oder macht doch auch Copa Amerika oder jetzt der Afrika Cup. Da wird es, da werden wir weiter sehr defensiv sein, weil wir eben gesehen haben, es war schon ein bisschen zu viel, was der Rasenfunk in den letzten Jahren gemacht hat. Das sehen wir ja auch in den Downloads. Und wir haben es in der Hörerinnenbefragung wirklich gespiegelt bekommen von vielen Leuten, dass sie es nicht schaffen, alles zu hören, dass es dann eher fast ein frustrierendes Gefühl ist. Deswegen, da wird jetzt erst mal nichts Neues geplant, auch wenn Afrika Cup rein am Termin liegt. Ich konnte jetzt einfach nicht über Weihnachten auch noch arbeiten.
Und ihr dürft dabei auch nicht vergessen, wenn wir über neue Ideen sprechen, über Afrika Cup, über Copa Amerika, über was auch immer, dann reden wir ja immer auch von sehr kleinen Nischen. Das heißt, das ist auch etwas, was wir einfach abwägen müssen und sagen, okay, das ist natürlich super interessant. Und uns oder im Zweifelsfall auf jeden Fall, Max interessiert ja auch irgendwie alles, was an Fußball passiert auf der Welt. Aber das Problem ist natürlich so ein bisschen, wir müssen ja auch darauf gucken, wie bringt es den Rasenfunk weiter? Also hilft es uns vielleicht auch ein bisschen, neue Hörer zu gewinnen oder was auch immer. Und das ist halt mit so einem Nischen Thema einfach wahnsinnig schwer. Im Gegensatz dazu läuft aber relativ viel Zeit rein, weil es natürlich ein Thema ist, mit dem man sich nicht natürlich schon gut auskennt, sondern man muss halt für den Afrika Cup nochmal extra recherchieren und sich mit Mannschaften, mit Nationalmannschaften auseinandersetzen, mit denen man sich vielleicht bisher nie auseinandergesetzt hat oder nur sehr wenig. Und das macht es immer noch zusätzlich schwierig zum Thema der Gesamtkomplexität oder Menge an Sendungen. Kommt eben das noch obendrauf, weil ja natürlich immer auch für uns ein Blick sein muss, so wie kann man eigentlich vielleicht neue T-Gruppen erschließen, neue Hörer finden etc. Und das ist natürlich mit so Nischen-Themen schwierig. Die gibt es sicherlich, da gäbe es sicherlich die Afrika Cup-Fans, die dann, wenn man das regelmäßig machen würde, den Rasenfunk finden würden. Aber natürlich wahrscheinlich nicht in Zahlen, die am Ende spürbar sind.
Also wir haben ja bestimmt schon drei Turniere entsprechend gecovert und da wäre mir keinerlei Entwicklung in irgendeiner Richtung aufgefallen bei den Zahlen oder auch bei den Kommentaren. Ehrlicherweise für mich sind diese Zielgruppen und Reichweiten-Themen nachgelagert. Für mich ist das viel größere Thema, was bei mir im Kopf immer sehr präsent ist, dass du gerade bei so Nischen-Themen und wir sind ja eh schon eine Nische im Segment Fußball und wenn wir dann noch nischiger werden, da hast du das große Problem, dass die Leute, die sich dafür wirklich interessieren, die kennen sich dann so gut aus, dass ihnen die Art und Weise, wie wir es besprochen haben, dann auch nicht reicht. Und für andere ist es, wenn du noch tiefer reingehst, eine noch größere Hürde reinzukommen, weil sie die Spielernamen nicht zuordnen können und so weiter und so fort. Also ich nenne es, in meinem Kopf ist das das Super League Paradox. Ich hatte sehr oft, als wir die Ligatur noch ein bisschen anders gestaltet haben und auf einzelne Ligen geblickt haben, da gab es ja manchmal auch Super League Segmente mit Fati Demireli noch. Den kann ich jetzt nicht mehr fragen, der Sportdirektor bei Gala, der redet jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anders, wenn er noch öffentlich reden kann, kann ich ihn nicht mal als neutrale Quelle verwenden. Aber da war das schon das Problem, dass damals immer wieder Super League Fans mir gesagt haben, ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch einen meiner Nachbarn grüßen, mach doch mehr Super League. Und wenn ich dann was zur Super League gemacht habe, haben sie gesagt, ja da war ja nichts Neues mit dabei. Ja genau, weil du kennst dich an der Super League aus. Und darüber denke ich ehrlich gesagt mehr nach, als über Zielgruppenfragen.
Aber es ist auch beides schwer zu messen. Also sowohl der Gewinn, wie du jetzt gesagt hast, nach den Turnieren zu sehen, tut sich da jetzt irgendwo was, ist einfach statistisch wahnsinnig schwer zu messen. Wir kommen da auch kleiner bei den Hörerfragen drauf. Leider sehen wir in den Statistiken gar nicht so viel, wie wir gerne sehen würden. Oder Dinge, die uns vielleicht manchmal interessieren oder weiterhelfen würden. So ein Podcast ist halt am Ende ein Download und was dann damit passiert. Ob es jetzt gerade ein paar mehr sind oder nicht, das verändert sich ja sowieso bei jeder Folge ein bisschen. Alles schwer zu beurteilen und genauso schwer zu sagen, wie viele davon dann am Ende jetzt zufrieden waren mit der Tiefe oder nicht. Da müssen wir ein Stück weit einfach auch auf die eigene Intuition vertrauen.
Das und eben tatsächlich das Feedback von euch. Also wenn euch was wirklich am Herzen liegt, dann geht ins Forum. Das ist wirklich der wichtigste Ort für mich, weil auf allen anderen Kanälen da werde ich ganz schön zugeballert. Ich kriege auch unverhältnismäßig oft E-Mails auch auf gar nicht meine Rasenfunkadresse, weil eben Leute irgendwie den Kontakt zu mir suchen wollen oder sie schreiben mir aufs private Profil bei Instagram und so weiter und so fort. Und da ist aber das Grundrauschen so hoch, dass ich da schon alles sehe und auch das allerallermeiste davon beantworte. Aber wenn es im Forum landet und wenn wir im Forum sehen, da ist irgendwann eine Community aus 10, 20 Leuten, die sich über Themen unterhält, zu denen sie auch gerne Sendungen hätten und wir sehen, die sind da, die sind engagiert. Vielleicht kann man da sogar Gäste daraus rekrutieren, dann ist der Schritt vielleicht auch ein bisschen einfacher. Also das Forum ist schon wichtig.
Und weil wir schon da sind, habe ich nochmal zwei Aspekte dazu. Zum einen unterschätzt nicht, wie viel Einfluss ihr damit auf uns nehmt, weil diese Diskussionen im Forum einfach gesehen werden und zum anderen, wenn ihr darüber nachdenkt, uns Feedback zu Sendungen zu geben, zu Gästen, zu Moderatoren, was auch immer, tut es bevorzugt im Forum, weil zum einen kriegt ihr damit automatisch gleich einen Abgleich. Bin ich der Einzige, der es so sieht oder was sagt die Community dazu? Und ihr nehmt uns ein bisschen den Druck, so ein Brett an E-Mail-Feedback persönlich beantworten zu müssen innerhalb von einem bestimmten Zeitraum. Weil wir das natürlich auch wollen. Wir wollen ja nicht irgendwie alles untergehen lassen. Und im Forum ist einfach der beste Platz dafür. Also wenn ihr darüber nachdenkt, uns da Feedback zu geben, und da freuen wir uns so oder so drüber. Aber tut es bitte im Forum. Da ist es einfach am besten aufgehoben. Und dann habt ihr so ein bisschen das Community Feedback auch gleich dazu.
Das ist tatsächlich ein wichtiger Punkt. Und im Forum findet man es auch noch wieder. Also gerade bei Tribünengesprächen oder alten Sendungen. Ich gucke schon immer mal wieder, wenn ich auch bei uns auf der Webseite unterwegs bin, schaue ich in den alten Kommentarstrangen rein, was eigentlich damals so kommentiert wurde. Das ist zum Beispiel, wenn ihr bei Discord Feedback gebt, wisst ihr ja auch alle, die dort aktiv sind in unserem inoffiziellen Discord Server, auf unserem Server. Da ist das verschwunden, da ist das für immer weg. Da findest du nichts Altes wieder. Also ihr Cracks, da kriegt das schon hin bei Discord. Ich grüße euch in dieser Stelle sehr herzlich, aber niemand normal.
Ihr zwei, die verstehen, wie es funktioniert.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ein paar mehr sind es doch, Frank. Das haben wir nicht so gemeint. Es ist ja sehr flauschig und netter.
Aber ich muss leider Discord auch aus verschiedenen Gründen quasi täglich nutzen und ich hadere ständig damit. Das sind keine technischen Gründe.
Ja, warum es keinen offiziellen Rasenfunk Discord Server gibt, haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal erklärt hier an dieser Stelle. Für uns ist Plattform-Unabhängigkeit sehr wichtig. Deswegen unser eigenes Forum. Und es hat sich schon so oft bewährt.
Bewert, genau.
Ja, also da könnten wir noch mal alte Slack-Diskussionen hier euch noch mal nach erzählen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gut, dass wir nie einen Slack eingerichtet haben. Und vielleicht ist das auch ein Grund, warum es uns auf anderen Kanälen nicht gibt. Also ich weiß, dass WhatsApp-Gruppen zum Beispiel gerade sehr beliebt sind bei Podcasts. Aber auch das Thema, wo man wirklich zu WhatsApp und Twitter ist nochmal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Bitte, bitte geht nicht mehr auf Twitter. Ich möchte den Radfot da aufstellen.
Aber tatsächlich, um ehrlich zu sein, WhatsApp haben wir im letzten Jahr mehrfach diskutiert und das ist auf keinen Fall vom Tisch. Also falls das für euch etwas ist, wo ihr euch zu Hause fühlt, warum auch immer. Persönlich kann ich es nicht verstehen, aber da denken wir tatsächlich drüber nach, was zu machen. Da wird sich vielleicht noch was tun, aber auch da ist nichts spruchreif, wenn wir schon noch in dem Segment des Ausblicks aufs kommende Jahr, also auf dieses vor uns stehende Jahr sind. Auch da gibt es noch nichts Handfestes. Und jetzt gehen wir vielleicht zu den Hörerfragen, Max.
Jetzt gehen wir zu den Hörerfragen. Magst du mir die erste vorlesen? Weil die kann ich dann beantworten und du gerne noch ergänzen, wenn du magst.
Die von Phil? Ja. Phil schreibt, Moin, könnt ihr anhand der Kapitel in euren Spieltagsbesprechungen nachvollziehen, ob bestimmte Segmente oder Vereine mehr gehört werden? Sind das die großen Vereine oder gibt es da interessante Ausreißer? Das war das, was ich gerade schon angesprochen habe mit den Fragen zur Statistik. Max, sag doch mal was dazu.
Ja, danke. Es war jetzt ein bisschen awkward, aber ich glaube, ich musste ganz dringend was trinken und mich reuspern.
Alles gut.
Also, wir könnten es vielleicht, wenn wir einen Spotify-Zugang hätten bei YouTube, können wir rein theoretisch sehen, wie die Wiedergabe über den Verlauf der Sendung ist. Da gibt es kleinere Peaks bei Bayern und Dortmund-Segmenten, aber ansonsten überhaupt nichts, was überraschend würde und ehrlicherweise auch nicht in einem nennenswerten Ausmaß, was mich sehr stolz macht. Ich finde das sehr gut, dass das jetzt eigentlich nicht das Allerwichtigste für euch ist, was wir über Bayern und Dortmund gesagt haben. Die einzige andere Plattform, bei der wir das rein theoretisch sehen könnten, wäre Spotify, aber auf Spotify haben wir nicht mal Zugriff. Also wir lesen da auch logischerweise keine Kommentare, wenn ihr die da veröffentlicht. Ihr wisst hoffentlich, wenn ihr das hier hört, dass wir persönlich Spotify sehr kritisch gegenüberstehen, sowohl in unserer Privatmeinung, aber vor allem auch als Rasenfunk. Spotify unterstützt so etwas wie den Rasenfunk 0,0, denn wir sind die völlig falsche Art von Format für Spotify. Deswegen tauchen wir da auch in den Rankings nicht auf. Deswegen bekommen wir nie irgendeine Hilfe von Spotify. Und wir sehen eben das große Problem der Plattformabhängigkeit. Wir wollen nicht, dass uns das auf die Füße fällt, dass irgendwann wir zu 70 Prozent über Spotify gehört werden und dann Spotify anfängt, sich bezahlen zu lassen, dafür, dass man Hörern angezeigt wird. Deswegen, wir können uns bei Spotify, wir haben ja neulich mal festgestellt, wir können ja nicht mal nachgucken, wenn wir wollten. Wir haben da ja nicht mal ein Login.
Genau, das läuft bei uns automatisch über Polygy, die Veröffentlichung bei Spotify. Und da haben wir nie irgendwie Zugriff. Vielleicht hätten wir es irgendwie, aber wir wussten es zumindest beide nicht.
Wir haben ja kein Login. Das hätten wir in unserem Passportmanager. Da sind wir zu gut organisiert, Frank.
Wir haben es irgendwie zumindest, ja, haben wir keinen Zugriff darauf im Moment auf jeden Fall. Und vielleicht auch gleich nochmal, weil der nächste Kommentar von Carrowa sich darauf bezieht. Der hat nämlich ein bisschen recherchiert, welche Plattformen das tracken, sozusagen dieses Überspringen von Segmenten. Das ist zwar in der Theorie so und auch in der Praxis. Bei YouTube, Max hat gesagt, man sieht bei einzelnen Videos kann man den Hörverlauf oder den Zuschauerverlauf sehen über die Zeit. Aber es gibt nichts, was uns das statistisch auswerten lassen würde. Bei YouTube ist nämlich das dumme, man weiß nicht aus anderen Hintergründen. Man kann da zwar über Schnittstellen auf einige Daten bei YouTube zugreifen, auch auf die statistischen Daten, um die selber mit eigenen Tools oder anderen externen Tools auszuwerten, aber leider nicht in der Tiefe. Also zum Beispiel auf diese Statistiken kommt man nicht programmatisch drauf, um jetzt irgendwie eine Auswertung über hunderte von Videos zu machen. Das wäre sehr kompliziert und man kommt so einfach in die Daten eben nicht ran. Also auch wenn die Plattformen das tracken und wahrscheinlich ganz viel damit machen und Spotify macht vielleicht seine Werbeplatzierung damit oder und YouTube wahrscheinlich auch und Apple wird mit Sicherheit auch irgendwie in aggregierter Form mit den Statistiken arbeiten. Aber ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht, ob es bei Apple so ist. Die haben ja mittlerweile auch ein bisschen bessere Statistiken. Aber grundsätzlich, viele Apps machen es eben gar nicht. Die tracken es gar nicht und geben entsprechend auch keine Statistiken darüber. Zumal wir jetzt sowieso von Pocketcasts keinerlei Statistiken haben. Also wenn überhaupt nur das über Pocketcasts gehört wurde. Genau. Und Pocketcasts selber sieht halt den Download und sieht, das ist die Pocketcasts-App. Aber was da drin passiert, dafür müsste es ja auch ein Standard geben. Weil Pocketcasts müsste das dann ja nicht nur an Pocketcasts, sondern eben an die ganzen vielen anderen Hosts in irgendeiner Form als Informationen weitergeben. Und da wäre mir nicht bekannt, dass es irgendeinen Standard dafür gibt. Und vielleicht ist es am Ende auch ganz gut so. Ich sehe es jetzt zwar nicht als super private Thema. Und eigentlich wäre es ja auch eine Art von Feedback-Möglichkeit zu sagen, wenn so und so viele Hörer dieses Segment überspringen, dann heißt es im Umkehrschluss wohl, lasst ihr lieber was anderes einfallen inhaltlich so an den Podcaster. Insofern würde ich es jetzt gar nicht so kritisch sehen. Aber wie gesagt, mir wäre nichts bekannt. Und ich will gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt, überurteilen, jetzt ob ich es gut fände oder nicht, oder ob es problematisch wäre oder nicht.
Also ich interessiere mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt 0,0. Also was wäre jetzt quasi die Konsequenz daraus, wenn wir sehen würden, Segmente zu bestimmten Vereinen werden erwartbar ein bisschen weniger gehört, als die zu anderen bekannten Vereinen. Machen wir dann die Segmente kürzer, lassen wir die Segmente weg. Wie viele Leute enttäuschen wir dann damit, die gerne alles... Also wir würden doch eh nichts verändern, weil wir ja nicht sozialen getrieben sind.
Genau, das war jetzt für mich auch nur ein Beispiel generell für Podcasts, das als Feedback-Möglichkeit zu haben für uns und das wisst ihr ja auch, zählt ja schon so ein bisschen, also zum einen natürlich die Überzeugung einfach zu sagen, wir wollen möglichst breit alles covern und wollen es nicht daran festmachen, ob jetzt ein Verein besonders beliebt ist oder nicht oder ob uns mehr Bayern-Hörer als FCE-Hörer hören oder was auch immer, weil dann wären wir ja direkt wieder in der gleichen Maschinerie, die wir ansonsten an traditionellen Sportmedien kritisieren. Insofern würde es uns wahrscheinlich ohnehin nicht beeinflussen, wäre vielleicht eher was für die Neugier, aber...
Exakt, das ist es nämlich. Es werden eh schon genügend Daten gesammelt und ja klar, es gibt zweimal im Jahr gibt es den Moment, wo ich mich ärgere, dass ich nicht sehen kann, wie viele Leute auf unsere, auf die Links in den Newslettern klicken, die wir rausschicken. Und an allen anderen Tagen im Jahr ist es mir aber egal. Und dann ist es eigentlich richtig, dass wir diese Daten nicht sammeln, auch wenn sie anonymisiert und alles und so weiter werden, weil wir eben grundsätzlich versuchen wenig Daten zu sammeln. Das ist schon in Ordnung so. Es muss auch solche Orte im Internet geben. Und vielleicht an der Stelle noch der Hinweis, weiß nicht, ob du es auch schon gesehen hast, solltet ihr von WhatsApp nicht zu Signal gewechselt sein, weil es bei Signal ein bisschen frickeliger war in der Vergangenheit, sein Backup zu sichern von allen Chats und Nachrichten. Das gibt es jetzt. Es gibt es jetzt genauso komfortabel wie bei WhatsApp. Ein Grund, weniger bei WhatsApp zu sein. Aber das ist jetzt nur ein ganz privater Take hier noch. Machen wir weiter mit einer Frage von Hakuna Matata. Er fragt einmal, ich denke uns beide, mal ganz klassisch, was sind die Jahresziele der Rasenfunk EMBH für das kommende Jahr? Frank, hast du uns eine Powerpoint mitgebracht? Ja, vor allem Powerpoint.
Nein, tatsächlich. Ich bin noch dabei an den KPIs.
Da muss erst noch eine Kidne hin rüber schauen.
Ja, genau. Nein, tatsächlich. Zieldefinitionen waren nie so mein Ding. Vielleicht, leider, vielleicht, Gott sei Dank, ich weiß es gar nicht. Aber es ist einfach nicht so mein Ding. Und für den Rasenfunk ist es ja auch tatsächlich schwer. Ich meine, natürlich, wir haben, glaube ich, schon öfter darüber gesprochen. Natürlich ist uns wichtig, dass der Rasenkunft Rasenfunk in Zukunft funktioniert. Natürlich würden wir gerne ein bisschen wachsen. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so ein Wachstum forever. Und nur maximales Wachstum ist gutes Wachstum. Sondern eigentlich eben nur, weil wir natürlich wissen, dass immer auch hinten was wegfällt. Jemand, der einen nicht mehr hören will, der vielleicht vom Fußball genug hat, der einen nicht mehr unterstützen will. Unser Wachstumsgedanke geht eigentlich in erster Linie aus einem Erhaltungstrieb heraus, würde ich sagen.
Und um steigende Kosten aufzufangen, muss man auch dazu sagen. Alle Arbeits- und so weiter, es wird konstant teurer. Das müssen wir halt auffangen jedes Jahr.
Genau, aber eben nicht aus so einem, naja, wir wollen ja genau in drei Jahren das doppelte Gehalt bekommen oder so.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht in die Börse gehen und müssen irgendwie unsere Zahlen noch schon frisieren.
Genau. Und unsere Gedanken gehen da immer, wir haben das ja in der Vergangenheit schon öfter besprochen, auch in Richtung finden wir vielleicht noch mehr Moderatoren, die was übernehmen können, um Max ein bisschen zu entlasten, um vielleicht auch Ideen umsetzen zu können und so was. Aber das ist ganz schlecht, als Ziel in ein Jahresziel zu packen, weil Moderatorenkandidaten wachsen nicht auf den Bäumen. Und wir haben es ja vorhin schon gesagt, da wir uns jetzt auch nicht an Trends orientieren oder an Statistiken, ist es auch ganz schwer, gezielt zu wachsen. Das ist einfach ein schwieriges Thema. Insofern würde ich sagen, es gibt keine Jahresziele.
Also wir wollen die 3% Steigerung, die wir bei den Gästehonoraren drin haben, die wollen wir als GmbH eben auch so grob haben. Wobei genau drei müssten es nicht sein, weil kann man ja dann umrechnen. Wir geben ja nicht 100% des Geldes für Gäste aus. Aber so ein bisschen mehr wollen wir dazu haben. Ich finde auch, dass es kaum fassbare Ziele dafür gibt. Vor allem auch, und das ist vielleicht ein Aspekt, den ich an der Stelle nochmal reinbringen kann, der Sportjournalismus sich gerade wieder verändert. Und das ist sowieso schon ein Transformationsprozess. Es ist nicht mehr so, wie wir vor elf Jahren, als wir vor elf Jahren angefangen haben, da sah die Welt auch im Sportjournalismus noch anders aus. Vieles ist seitdem besser geworden, meiner Meinung nach. Vieles hat sich auch im Podcastbereich getan. Wir sind nicht mehr der größte Fußballpodcast. Wir sind vielleicht der größte Independent-Fußballpodcast. Wobei man selbst da vielleicht noch Diskussionen sogar führen könnte. Aber generell verändert sich gerade im Sportjournalismus wieder so einiges. Also ohne jetzt in die Tiefe zu gehen. Aber ihr könnt mal die neuen Eigentümer von Sport1, könnt ihr euch mal zusammensuchen, was deren Ausrichtung betrifft. Ihr könnt mal verfolgen, was gerade RTL aktuell, jetzt dann wahrscheinlich, ich glaube heute sogar, tatsächlich verkünden wird. Ihr könnt mal angucken, was mit anderen Sportredaktionen so passiert ist. Ihr könnt angucken, was mit lokalen Tageszeitungen passiert, wie sich da immer mehr so ein Oligopol aus verschiedenen großen Verlagen herausbildet. Und ich kann euch aus Sicht von Freiberuflerinnen und Freiberuflern sagen, dass es wirklich ein rauer Wind ist, der gerade weht. Aus verschiedenen Gründen auch unter anderem den neuen Rundfunkstaatsvertrag, beziehungsweise jetzt eine Änderung, die jetzt dann in Kraft wurde, dürfen nämlich zum Beispiel auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender auch im Sportbereich viel, viel weniger online machen. Es muss jetzt immer ein direkter Programmbezug hergestellt werden. Das alles haben wir der Lobby der Verlegerinnen und Verleger Deutschlands zu verdanken. Das heißt, für Freiberuflerinnen und Freiberufler, auch im Sportjournalismus, ist die Situation nicht besser geworden. Und ich kenne so einige, die damit ganz schön zu kämpfen haben, die auch eine große Ungewissheit haben. Ich kenne auch einige, die deshalb den Sportjournalismus oder den Sportteil in ihrem Journalismus und zum Teil auch den Journalismus generell an den Nagel gehängt haben. Das merkt ihr indirekt auch, wenn wir Probleme haben, Gäste zu finden. Wenn manche Gäste nicht mehr zu hören sind, dann hat es manchmal auch damit zu tun. Also da ist sehr viel gerade im Wandel. Umso dankbarer sind wir, dass es wie immer bisher in der Vergangenheit den Rasenfunk bisher gar nicht betrifft. Wir können unser Produkt einfach so weiter durchziehen, wie wir es mal aufgesetzt haben, weil wir anders finanziert werden. Aber in Online-Redaktionen generell und in Sport-Redaktionen auch, es geht ein großes Gespenst um. Und das heißt, Klickverluste durch KI, weil eben die Leute, die KI-Zusammenfassungen legen, aber nicht mehr auf die Seite klicken. Generell Reichweitenvermarktung funktioniert immer schlechter im Online-Journalismus und die Arbeitsbedingungen werden nicht besser. Auch durch manche Entwicklungen in den sozialen Netzwerken. Also das alles ist der Kontext, in dem letztlich auch die GmbH steht, in dem wir auch unsere Ziele definieren müssten. Und das ist dann mal wirklich komplex. Das ist anders als manch andere Dinge, die derzeit als komplex bezeichnet werden in unserer Welt. Das leitet vielleicht auch so ein bisschen über zum zweiten Teil der Frage von Hakuna Matata. Das kann ich jetzt kürzer machen. Er verweist unter anderem auf die Zweitligatur von Eva und Mark und auf die Kooperation bezüglich der Gruppe Amerika mit Johannes Eskiber. Und ob ich mir vorstellen könnte, mehr Sendungen abzugeben, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber es ist alles nicht ganz so trivial, weil man auch sagen muss, das Moderieren vom Rasenfunk ist noch mal was komplett anderes als Gast zu sein. Und zwar vor allem, was den Aufwand betrifft. Und das spiegelt sich noch nicht komplett in der Entlohnung wider. Wir haben da natürlich schon versucht, fair zu sein. Und wir wissen auch, dass alle, die bei uns moderieren, das so empfinden, weil das ist die Grundlage dafür, dass wir das überhaupt abgeben wollen. Aber es hängt schon viel dran, viel Aufwand. Dafür müssen dann die Moderierenden die Zeit haben und das auch machen wollen. Wir müssen es sein können. Grundsätzlich können wir uns da viel vorstellen, aber es wird also auf absehbare Zeit wird das schon so sein, dass einfach der Großteil des Rasenfunks wird moderativ von mir getragen werden müssen. Weil für mich ist es der Hauptberuf. Ich mache nichts anderes. Den ganzen Tag Rasenfunk rauf und runter. Deswegen kann ich auch alle Kommentare lesen, die ihr da draußen so zum Beispiel schreibt. Also das wird, wenn dann eher in kleinen Schritten funktionieren und das wird da nicht so den einen großen Schritt geben. Auch weil das glaube ich auch nicht, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich hier zehn Bewerbungen pro Tag bekomme von Menschen, die sagen, hey, ich will auf jeden Fall mal ein Rasenfunk moderieren. Das muss man schon auch mal sagen.
Nichtsdestotrotz gucken wir trotzdem auf die Work-Life-Balance.
Ja.
Schönes Passwort von Max und unter anderem ist ja auch die Tatsache, zum Beispiel mit den Schwerpunkten. Als wir beim letzten Mal bei der Klausur zusammensaßen, beziehungsweise ich glaube, das war das Thema im Sommer, also beim vorletzten Mal, haben wir dieses Thema besprochen und haben ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie können wir vereinzelte Formate neu organisieren. Max hat es vorhin schon angesprochen, ich wollte es nur noch mal in dem Kontext erwähnen, was eben Reduktion angeht, auch um nicht die permanente ganz hohe Masse an Output zu liefern und auch ein bisschen inhaltlich auf das Wichtige zu fokussieren. Und das spielt natürlich auch beim Thema Work-Life-Balance ein bisschen mit rein.
Und das ist ja schon viel besser geworden. Also bei uns beiden ist es so, 2024 war ein wirklich heftiges Jahr in allen Belangen. Und eben auch ganz wesentlich, was den Rasenfunk angeht, 2025 hatte da schon eine ganz andere Note und eine ganz andere Temperatur für uns beide, auch wenn es so ein bisschen asynchron zwischen uns liefert. Du natürlich mit der Webseite sehr, sehr viel zu tun hattest. Aber also zumindest für mich kann ich sagen, war 2025 viel eher noch in einem Rahmen, der auch funktionieren kann auf Dauer. 2024, so wie wir da rausgeballert haben, aus verschiedensten Gründen, das wäre keine zwei Jahre mehr so gut gegangen.
Genau, aber das sind natürlich immer Sachen, das muss man auch dann immer ein bisschen selbstkritisch sehen. Und wenn man drin steckt in diesem Outputstrom und in diesem Mechanismus, dann sieht man es meistens gar nicht so gut. Und da haben wir aber Gott sei Dank geschafft, auch durch unsere Klausuren, die da immer wieder fast schon legendär sind für uns, das ein bisschen eben dann, naja, eben ich ein bisschen von außen drauf zu gucken, was Max angeht und dann ein bisschen zu korrigieren. Und da sind wir ganz froh, dass das jetzt so läuft, wie es jetzt läuft. Aber da steht am Schluss noch die Frage, Max, was sind in der Hinsicht die Lieblingsformate von Max?
Komm, sag's, sag's endlich. Ach, ich kann es nicht sagen. Es wechselt, ich kann es nicht sagen. Also natürlich macht mir die Ligatur Europa Spaß, auch wenn es natürlich schon schade ist, dass da nur Männer zu hören sind. Aber das hat auch Gründe. Also wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der weiblich ist und da eine Expertise hat, sagt es mir gerne weiter. Die, die ich bisher gefunden habe, die konnten sich das alle aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht vorstellen. Aber mir machen auch die Bundesligasendung so viel Spaß. Die Bundesliga der Frauen macht mir unheimlich viel Spaß, weil es da auch so ist. Also ich kenne, ich bekomme ja auch Feedback auf Sendungen direkt aus dem Bundesligan heraus. Jetzt nicht viel, also ihr müsst euch jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass hier Max Eberl anruft und sagt, Mensch, das ist aber richtig schön beschrieben, wie wir unser 2-0 geschossen haben. Das definitiv nicht. Aber es wird halt schon bei Vereinen gehört. Zum Teil zumindest. Und das hat bei der Bundesliga der Frauen noch mal eine andere Qualität als der Bundesliga bei der Bundesliga der Männer. Und allein deshalb macht mir dieses Format Freude, weil ich da ehrlicherweise manchmal auch einfach gespannt darauf bin, ob ich da eine Reaktion kriege nach Dingen, die wir in der Sendung gesagt haben, wie diese Reaktion auffällt und wie das quasi mein Hintergrundwissen zu dieser Liga verändert. Aber auch die Tribünengespräche machen riesig Spaß. Ich meine, ich würde, du kannst mich nachts um drei wecken, kannst sagen, willst du mit Jürgen Kalver drei Stunden sprechen? Und ich würde nicht mal nach einem Thema fragen. Ich würde sagen, okay, alles klar, lass mir noch eine Hose anziehen. Dann legen wir los. Also deswegen, es gibt nicht das eine Lieblingsformat. Das hört man ja hoffentlich den Sendungen auch an.
Und am Ende sind es Podcasts. Das sollte jetzt auch an der Hose nicht scheitern, eigentlich, wenn wir ehrlich sind.
Da hast du dann wohl recht. Die nächste Frage von du, die haben wir schon...
Hosenzwang ist aufgehoben, war mal früher so ein klassischer Spruch.
Ja, das versteht heutzutage keiner mehr.
Aus Twitter-Zeiten war das gleich, als Twitter noch Twitter war. Ach Gott, melancholisch. Ich glaube, den Post von Yuvi können wir überspringen. Yuvi, wir hoffen, wir haben es vorhin schon ausreichend erklärt, warum Gehälter und Honorare und Gäste Honorare quasi irgendwie doppelt aussehen. In den Zahlen. Dann kommen wir zu Ari Knizlo.
Ja, exakt.
Ich muss ja noch mich bemühen. Magst du den machen, Max?
Ich versuche, ihn zusammenzufassen, weil es ist ein längerer Kommentar. Er referiert auf das Tribünengespräch Nazis in Cottbus, das jetzt auch wirklich schon viele Jahre alt ist, und fragt uns, ob wir generell zum Rechtsdruck der Gesellschaft, der sich ja auch im Fußball bemerkbar macht, mal etwas machen könnten. Also er schreibt, er hätte gerne da eine, vielleicht sogar eine historische Einordnung. Er könnte sich das als Storytelling-Podcast vorstellen. Könnte ich alles auch und fragt eben, ob es dazu mal was geben könnte. Ich kann dazu tatsächlich sogar so halb konkret etwas sagen, und zwar, warum es in der Vergangenheit so selten weitere Themen zu diesem Thema gab. Also zu eben der Frage, wo drängen Nazis, vereinfacht gesprochen in den Fußballreihen? Und was kann dagegen getan werden? Wie ist das Ganze einzuordnen? Wie verhalten sich die Verantwortlichen? Es ist extrem schwierig, dazu Gesprächspartnerinnen zu finden. Ich hatte da zum Teil schon konkrete Zusagen. Ich hatte da aber auch dann schon unter der Maßgabe, die Stimme wird doppelt verzarrt, damit nicht nachvollziehbar ist. Dann, okay, wir sprechen dann im Nachhinein das Interview neu an. Und so weiter und so fort. Ich hatte zum Teil auch schon Journalistinnen und Journalisten, die aber, wenn sie in diesem Bereich sehr tief unterwegs sind, also nicht nur Feindbild sind und deswegen natürlich mit öffentlichen Äußerungen zurückhaltend sein müssen, die aber auch in der Regel komplett überarbeitet sind, weil das nur erschreckend wenige in Deutschland sind, die sich wirklich in diese Themenkomplexe richtig tief reinarbeiten. Deswegen, es gab schon mehrmals dazu so halbkonkrete Planungen, in einem Fall sogar sehr konkrete Planungen, die dann ganz kurzfristig eben abgesagt wurden und zwar für immer. Deswegen, es ist für uns auch ein wichtiges Thema, das wisst ihr ja. Und das wird auch aus dem Rasenfunk nicht verschwinden. Allein deshalb, weil wir auch an der Stelle sehr gerne nochmal sagen, wenn ihr wirklich nichts besseres zu tun habt, als die AfD zu wählen, wenn ihr wirklich glaubt, von dieser Partei seien Lösungen zu erwarten, die gut für dieses Land werden, dann möchten wir euch weder als Hörer noch als SupporterInnen, wir wollen mit euch nichts zu tun haben. Ich will auch keine Kommentare von euch bei YouTube lesen. Bitte sucht euch einfach viele andere Ecken im Internet, sind braun genug für euch. Und ich will jetzt nicht die Diskussion, sind alle AfD-Wähler Nazis führen, aber jeder der AfD wählt Nazis und dementsprechend hat er mit dem Wertekassett des Rasenfunk so gar nichts zu tun. Wir können uns gerne drüber unterhalten, warum ihr unzufrieden seid, aber die Lösung kann nicht sein, Nazis zu wählen. Das kann ich an der Stelle noch mal sagen. Und es wird auch sicher weiter Sendungen dazu geben, aber es ist leider tatsächlich schwierig. Es ist wirklich total interessant, da so seinen Fuß reinzuhalten in diese Szene der Journalisten.
Und auch wenn ich das jetzt nur aus meiner persönlichen Sicht sagen kann und gar nicht aus dem Hintergrund wie Max, was die Gesprächspartner angeht, ich glaube, es wird auch klar sein, für jeden, der die Welt beobachtet, wie sie sich jetzt im letzten Jahr entwickelt hat vor allem, noch mal verstärkt, dass das jetzt auch nicht leichter wird. Weil die Tendenzen sich immer weiter vor schieben in der Gesellschaft. Und das macht es nicht leichter, weil das Menschen entweder sich nicht trauen oder einfach nicht wollen, wollen wir mal über die Hintergründe gar nicht spekulieren, sich zu dem Thema zu äußern. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt erst mal so schnell nicht einfacher werden. Und um auf den Post im Forum von Arek Nizlo, ich finde keinen Weg, das flüssig auszusprechen, Arek Nizlo, zurückzukommen, ja, natürlich würden wir super gerne so ein Tribünengespräch machen und ich glaube, da steckt auch viel Stoff drin, aber ist eben schwierig ohne gute Gesprächspartner dazu.
Ja, und ein Stück weit auch, aber das liegt auch an mir halt der Anspruch, also so wie er oder sie hier schreibt, man hätte gerne quasi auch das Historische und die Einordnung und verschiedene Gruppen und das ist ja auch nicht schwarz und weiß in diesem Bereich oder in dem Fall braun und weiß, sondern da muss man ja auch gute Vorsätze, Max.
Du hast ja gute Vorsätze.
Ja genau, da habe ich mich jetzt auch gerade wieder dran gedacht.
Kurz noch mal dran erinnern, ist schon drei Minuten her, aber.
Ja ja, exakt, exakt, exakt. Vielleicht melde ich mich bei dem einen Experten, den ich da hatte schon mal. Da habe ich damals gedacht, da müsste ich eigentlich noch einen weiteren Experten und dann noch jemand aus der Fanszene und dann aber noch jemanden vom Verein, der sich dazu mal äußern kann. Und so ist quasi die Idee dann gestorben, weil ich sie zu groß gemacht habe. Vielleicht fange ich doch mal mit einem an. Ich nehme es mir vor. Jetzt haben wir es wieder gesagt. Also danke für den sehr guten Input auch. Also das war sehr schön zu sehen. Die nächste Frage hat der liebe Dux Kruk gestellt, auch Forums Power User und sie geht an dich, Frank. Behind the tech, warum war die Webseite mit 503 down? Also das ist eine Fehlermeldung an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bad Gateway ist es, glaube ich, oder? Und wie aufwendig ist die Maintenance, also eben das Pflegen, eigentlich so im Durchschnitt der Technik? Tja, jetzt darfst du abnöten.
Die Maintenance ist tatsächlich gar nicht so aufwendig. Der Rasenfunk ist grundsätzlich relativ wartungsarm, was das technische angeht, also den Website-Teil. Abgesehen von Updates, die wir dann mal für zwei Jahre auslassen und dann Monate lang Arbeit haben, um den alten Code wieder in Schwung zu bringen. Aber das ist mal was anderes. Aber im Normalbetrieb würde ich sagen gar nicht. Der Fehler war tatsächlich auch gar nicht direkt mit dem Rasenfunk verbunden. Da laufen auf dem Server noch zwei, drei andere Kleinigkeiten im Hintergrund. In dem Fall war es, was mit KI zusammenhängt, was einfach schlichtweg eine Datenbank vollgeschrieben hat, mehr oder weniger. Im weitesten Sinne könnte man jetzt sagen, einfach Logs vollgespuckt hat, ohne dass es jemand, und dieser jemand bin ich in dem Fall, gemerkt hat, weil man natürlich sich immer vornimmt, alles schön mit Metriken und Warnungen zu versehen. Und wenn die Festplatte mehr als 80 Prozent voll ist, habe ich leider zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht eingerichtet gehabt, gibt es aber jetzt. Die Festplatte war voll. Das war die einfache Ursache. Ich muss ein bisschen sauber machen und dann war alles wieder gut. Und ja, Aufwand ist überschaubar, was die Wartung angeht. Das läuft Gott sei Dank alles relativ stabil. Und leider muss man ja auch ein bisschen sagen, die Website hat leider nicht die Wichtigkeit, die wir ihr gerne selber geben würden und die wir eigentlich auch in die Entwicklung gesteckt haben, weil halt nur mal ein Podcast vorwiegend im Podcatcher stattfindet. Und ja.
Also das muss man kurz sagen, es hat nicht die Wichtigkeit von eurer Seite. Und da seid ihr jetzt aber wahrscheinlich nicht die angesprochenen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Sie wird einfach sehr wenig besucht von Menschen wie wir. Wir haben die Selbstseite konzipiert, um Menschen einen schnellen Überblick zu geben, was ist eigentlich der Rasenfunk, wie kann man den Rasenfunk unterstützen und wie finde ich mich in diesen Wust aus Sendungen aus fünf Formaten und so weiter zurecht. Und da haben wir sehr, sehr viel Zeit, Hirn schmalz, Liebe und Geld reingesteckt, um das eben wie wir finden, auf ein Niveau zu heben, das es im Podcastbereich vielleicht gar nicht so oft bei anderen gibt. Und müssen jetzt aber feststellen, so viele Menschen sind das gar nicht, die da in jedem Monat draufklicken. Also das Forum hat jeden Monat viel, viel mehr Views.
Du sagst es ja eigentlich schon. Wir haben tatsächlich durch einen Punkt vergessen. Wir haben nämlich eigentlich die Website auch so konzipiert, dass sie eigentlich gleich ein Podcatcher ist. Also sie ist ja auch als Player gut zu benutzen, vor allem weil man eben durch die Website surfen kann, während der Player läuft und so was. Dieser Punkt ist leider so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen für die Katze, das stimmt nicht, aber die Informationen und die Unterstützungsformen und so, das wäre wahrscheinlich, wenn wir heute nochmal neu über die Website nachdenken, mehr der Fokus als jetzt der Player und die technische Tiefe. Weil das tatsächlich eben leider auch in Spotify, aber auch in YouTube und auch in Apple Podcasts oder in Podcasts deiner Wahl, in Podcasts, in Overcasts und wie sie alle heißen stattfindet, was ja gut so ist, weil das ist ja alles, das auch, wofür wir Podcasts lieben und wofür wir froh sind, wenn wir gerade mal Zeit haben, was zu hören, einfach das Handy rausziehen zu können, Podcasts auf, auf Play drücken und fertig und nicht erst, ach, wie war nochmal die Website und dahin zu gehen und so. Das ist ja alles wunderbar. Insofern auch gar keine Beschwerde dahingehend, aber das ist eben so ein bisschen der Hintergrund und so, wie ich es gemeint habe, wenn ich sage, die hat leider nicht die Wichtigkeit, die wir, mit der wir sie geplant haben, kann man glaube ich so sagen und umgesetzt haben.
Beschwerde ja sowieso nicht. Also ihr hören und höre bestimmt ja, was ihr, was euch interessiert. Vielleicht wird die Bedeutung der Website auch für euch nochmal steigen. Sollten wir das irgendwann mit Transkripten zu Folgen hinbekommen. Aber da haben wir immer noch das Spielernamenproblem. Also wenn sich da draußen jemand damit auskennt, wie wir verlässlich es lösen könnten, dass gängige LLMs und andere mit den Spielernamen der Bundesligaspieler einfach nicht zurechtkommen wollen, wenn sie unsere Folgen transkribieren. Meldet euch bei uns. Bevorzug bei Frank. Ich leite ansonsten weiter. Ja, genau, wir haben es immer noch nicht von uns bekommen.
Gerne im Forum, schreibt mir eine PN im Forum, schreibt eine E-Mail über das Kontaktformular, was auch immer. Und schreibt auch gerne ins Forum, wenn ihr Feedback zur Website habt, auch jetzt zu den Neuerungen. Ich glaube, ich werde gleich, wenn wir fertig sind, mit der Aufnahme noch mal dort einen Post reinschreiben, kurz die Änderungen zusammenfassen. Und da könnt ihr dann mir gerne auch Feedback geben. Oder wenn ihr noch Probleme findet, die es bestimmt gibt. Ich habe da schon jetzt noch mal die letzten Tage ein paar Stunden rumgefallen an Kleinigkeiten. Aber da ist noch lange nicht alles perfekt. Oder wenn ihr auch sagt, Mensch, eigentlich würde ich mir auf der Website noch genau dies und jenes wünschen, gern raus damit. Wir können nicht garantieren, dass wir es umsetzen können oder werden. Aber über Input sind wir da sehr dankbar.
Aber wirklich. Ich habe eine Frage von Fipsa an dich, Frank. Nämlich bekommen wir Ed Helmi, falls ihr euch gefragt habt, wie man ihn im Forum anpingen kann. Unter Ed Helmi findet ihr ihn. Bekommen wir Helmi eigentlich mal wieder als Gast in einer Spieltagsfolge? Gegebenenfalls in der Superbowl-Folge. Na, Frank, wie schaut es aus?
Jetzt muss ich mich wieder outen. Als Fußballverweigerer wäre jetzt tatsächlich zu viel. Aber ich habe es ja, glaube ich, auch in den letzten Logbüchern immer schon mal gesagt. Mein Fußballinteresse ist tatsächlich der Rasenfunk. Also ich informiere mich über die Fußballgeschehenes über den Rasenfunk. Ich habe schon sehr lange kein ganzes Fußballspiel mehr gesehen. Muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen?
Reicht deine Aufmerksamkeit Spanne nicht mehr, was? Du TikTok-Kid.
Ich, ADHS, Opfer, ja genau. Tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, Aufmerksamkeit Spanne. Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber ich habe auch tatsächlich schon sehr lange kein Spielfilm mehr gesehen. Also Fernsehen ist tatsächlich aus meinem Leben ziemlich verschwunden. Fernsehen heißt jetzt YouTube. Sonst ändert sich nichts. Die Videolänge hat sich ein bisschen verändert wahrscheinlich. Ich schaue bei YouTube die Zusammenfassung der Sportschau Abonnenten an. Vorwiegend die von Bayern dann, weil es halt immer noch jetzt auch nicht, wenn es nicht mehr sonderlich emotional ist, aber immer noch so ein bisschen mein Verein ist. Und insofern, ich in einer Spieltagsfolge, das wäre tatsächlich ein ziemlicher Unfall. Ich könnte außer blöden Kommentaren nicht viel beitragen. Leider, ich finde es auch schade ein bisschen, aber der Rasenfunk wird weiterhin mein Herz und meine Leidenschaft bleiben. Aber der Fußball an sich ist schwierig. Funktioniert für mich nur noch sehr bedingt.
Du bist ja auch nicht alleine mit Frank. Also wir haben durchaus hin und wieder schon kleinere Probleme, Gäste zu finden. Vielleicht verändert sich dahingehend sogar noch mal was im Rasenfunk. Aber wenn das so käme, dann würdet ihr das eh als Erste erfahren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber das Schöne ist ja, dass wir feststellen durften in den letzten 11, 12 Jahren, wir müssen uns nicht nur über Fußball unterhalten. Früher waren unsere Close-Urtaugungen so, dass wir die ersten 20 Minuten bis vielleicht auch manchmal gerne Stunden erst mal nur über Fußball geredet haben und dann, wie geht es dir eigentlich so? Und dann ging es zum Rasenfunk. Brauchen wir gar nicht, um sieben Stunden am Stück miteinander zu reden. Das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Brauchen wir gar nicht, um am Ende der Klausur sagen zu müssen, wir müssen langsam mal ans Einfahren denken. Ja, exakt. Und eigentlich wäre das Gespräch noch gar nicht beendet. Aber so ist es halt.
So ist es halt.
Genau. Max, hat sich denn dein Fan-Sein in anderen Sportarten durch den Rasenfunk verändert? Ist das weggefallen aus Zeitgründen? Fragt der Fipsa weiter, ist dein Blick auch im Football z.B. taktischer geworden? Schaust du dir die Strukturen woanders ebenso kritisch an? Das ist eigentlich, also wer Max kennt, das kann ja eigentlich gar keine Frage sein. Ich glaube, es gibt kein Thema, wo Max sich die Strukturen nicht kritisch anschaut, das mit Sport zu tun hat. Oder bist du irgendwo noch reiner Sportkonsument? Das ist tatsächlich eine interessante Frage. Gibt es irgendwas? Gibt es irgendeinen Skispringen oder so? Das schaue ich mir eigentlich gern an, aber das interessiert mir überhaupt nicht, was da so strukturell beim Deutschen Skiverband so abgeht.
Nee, also ich war ja sehr neulich beim Skispringen und... Nee, auch da schaue ich mir zum Beispiel an, welche Art vom Publikum da hingeht und welche Lieder da gespielt werden und welche Lieder da gesungen werden. Also ich bin halt einfach ein Dauernörgler. Also was ich noch konsumiere neben Fußball, ist hauptsächlich tatsächlich inzwischen American Football. Also ich bin immer froh, wenn die Rasenfunk-Sendung am Sonntag in der Nacht so früh vorbei ist, dass ich von der Red Zone noch möglichst viel gucken kann. Manchmal springe ich da auch zwei Stunden zurück. Oder natürlich auch gerne, wenn das Team spielt, das ich sehr gerne habe, das sind die Green Bay Packers. Aber es ist ganz schwierig, ein kritischer Sportkonsument zu sein und am American Football nicht ungefähr 1000 Sachen zu finden, die einen da stören müssten. Also ich würde mich da definitiv nicht als befreitsehenden Fan betrachten, auch wenn ich die Sportart mag. Und ansonsten muss man leider festhalten, ich glaube, ich habe das auch schon ein paar Mal hier erzählt, der Rasenfunk hat für mich andere Sportarten tatsächlich ein bisschen getötet. Denn früher war ich jemand, der immer alles geguckt hat. Also Handball, Skisport, da lief alles, lief einfach immer auf einem weiteren Monitor.
Realistisch betrachtet, wie soll es funktionieren, bei gefühlten 850 Stunden Fußball pro Woche?
Ja, vor allem, ich möchte jetzt einfach nicht mehr den, ich möchte einfach den Fernseher nicht mehr laufen haben. Also ich bin vielleicht einfach zu alt geworden dafür jetzt oder weil ich Kinder habe. Aber das tut mir auch manchmal für meine Töchter leid, weil ich weiß, wie schön das auch sein kann, einfach Sport sich anzugucken. Und man fühlt sich ja davon inspiriert. Also neben Fußball habe ich total gerne auch Basketball gespielt bei uns zu Hause im Hof. Und das hatte ganz wesentlich damit zu tun, dass ich Basketball gesehen habe und gesehen habe, wie man das so grob macht und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich will einfach nicht die ganze Zeit noch Sport laufen haben. Ich sehe dann auch viele Dinge kritisch, gerade am Wintersport. Ich kenne mich halbwegs gut aus in vielen Sportarten, weil ich dann über das Sportradio 360 zum Beispiel sehr viel konsumiere und natürlich halt in dieser Bubble unterwegs bin und mich eben rein theoretisch dafür interessiere. Aber es ist wirklich krass zurückgegangen und dass ich mal irgendwie, also Formel 1 zum Beispiel ist auch aus anderen Gründen komplett runtergefallen, dass ich da jetzt mal dann das letzte Rennen noch irgendwie nebenher laufen lasse, während hier auch schon Bundesliga läuft, hängt halt nur damit zusammen, wenn ich weiß, okay, das will ich jetzt nicht komplett verpassen, sonst ärgere ich mich später, weil ich gucke es nie im Real Life, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich gucke auch keine Zusammenfassung davon. Aber leider hat mein Sportinteresse durch den Rasenfunk echt so einen kleinen Schlag bekommen, weil ich nicht die ganze Zeit den irgendeinen Display laufen will, auf das ich dann immer wieder drauf gucke. Das ist manchmal einfach zu viel, vor allem nach so einem Wochenende.
Und das ist halt doch so, man muss den Sport auch sehen. Ergebnisse lesen und so, okay, dann weiß ich jetzt auch ungefähr, wie weit ist Bayern diese Saison schon wieder vorne und so. Aber ich weiß halt trotzdem nicht, wie sie spielen und warum sieht jetzt eigentlich Leverkusen gerade nicht so gut aus. Keine Ahnung, was auch immer. Also man versteht den Kontext. Klar, wie gesagt, ich höre den Rasenfunk und weiß es dadurch natürlich in der Theorie, aber es ist immer noch was anderes, das dann selber auch zu sehen. Und dann hört man natürlich auch so eine inhaltlich tiefere Berichterstattung wie beim Rasenfunk anders, wenn man auch gesehen hat, wie die spielen und was da gerade kritisiert wird. Und das fehlt einem eben, wenn man es nicht mehr sieht. Übrigens, ich will noch ganz kurz die Kurve kriegen, warum ich gerade den Wintersport erwähnt habe vorhin, weil ich bin nämlich eigentlich gar kein Wintersport-Fan. Ich bin selber nie Ski gefahren und habe mich auch nie sonderlich für Skispringen oder ein bisschen mal für Biathlon interessieren können. Kannst du dir vorstellen, warum ich jetzt gerade trotzdem vom Wintersport gesprochen habe?
Was, weil ich in Innsbruck war beim Skispringen?
Nee, hat nichts mit dir zu tun. Weil ich auch ein bisschen inspiriert bin von einer Creatorin, von unserer lieben Caro Kipper, die seit einiger Zeit bei TikTok unter dem Namen, darum wollte ich noch ein Shoutout loswerden. Caro kennt ihr alle als Stammhörer des Rasenfunks sehr regelmäßig, nicht nur bei den Nationalteams, aber auch da zu Gast. Die hat seit einiger Zeit einen TikTok-Kanal. Ich glaube, es sind noch gar nicht so viele Videos. Und wurde mir mehr oder weniger zufällig vorgelegt vom Algorithmus, schätze ich mal. Oder vielleicht weil sie dem Rasenfunk folgt, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall Caro auf Eis nennt sie sich da und macht, finde ich, ganz fantastische Videos. Das hat mir sehr gefallen, obwohl wie gesagt Wintersport gar nicht so mein Ding ist. Aber ich finde einfach die Art und Weise, wie sie die Videos macht. Das Beste war eindeutig das mit der Lichterkette um den Hals. Caro, ganz liebe Grüße, wenn du das hörst. Super Videos. Ich bin treuer Abonnent und like jedes Video, das ich sehe. Einfach nicht nur um dich zu fördern, sondern einfach aus purer Begeisterung.
Das stimmt sehr gut, dass du das hier noch erwähnt hast. Ich bin ja auf TikTok nicht unterwegs. Deswegen habe ich mir das zwar mal angeguckt, als Caro es mir erzählt hat, aber es wird verlinkt in den Channels. Und ich weiß, dass Rasenfunke, Hörerinnen und Hörer auf TikToks unterwegs sind. Die haben uns jetzt zum Teil gefunden, als wir da selber noch aktiv waren. Also das vielleicht zu der Frage. Und dann haben wir noch eine letzte von Mich Boll, der fragt, wird es in Schwerpunkten oder in einem anderen Format auch ganzheitlich um Vereine gehen und nicht nur um deren Mannschaft? Und das ist tatsächlich eine höchst interessante Frage, denn ich habe die mir auch schon öfter gestellt in der Vergangenheit, weil wir ja in der Regel uns beschränken auf die Männermannschaft, es immer mal wieder aber Gäste gibt, vor allem natürlich Mara, die auf die anderen Abteilungen immer auch eingeht in den Folgen. Und ich bin ehrlicherweise da so ein bisschen hin und hergerissen, weil auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich schöner, den ganzheitlichen Blick zu haben. Auf der anderen Seite wird es aber da sehr bald noch mehr Überschneidung geben als jetzt. Also wenn du dann über die Wolfsburg Männer sprichst im Fußball, müsstest du eigentlich mindestens genauso lange über die Frauen im Fußball sprechen. Und dann hast du die anderen Abteilungen noch nicht besprochen.
Ich wollte ja sagen, was ist da mit der Badminton-Abteilung?
Exakt, exakt. Plus wir sind halt ein Fußballpodcast und ich kenne mich vor allem auch im Fußball aus. Und ich finde, es ist auch zu respektieren, wenn Leute auch durchaus manchmal Feedbacken, ehrlich gesagt interessiert mich das überhaupt nicht, was die Rollstuhl-BasketballerInnen dort machen. Auch wenn ich das natürlich schade finde, aber es ist auch stimmt auch, dass man das in einem Fußballpodcast nicht erwartet. Es ist jetzt die Frage, ob man sich da drin stören muss, würde ich jetzt sagen, ehrlicherweise auch nicht unbedingt. Aber ich respektiere dieses Feedback in dem Sinne, dass ich sage, ja, das kommt durchaus an dieser Stelle ein bisschen überraschend. Deswegen würde ich vermuten, lieber Michboll, dass das weiter so ist wie jetzt. Es ist dann einfach vom Gast abhängig. Wenn der Gast das möchte, dann rede ich da sehr gerne drüber und blicke auf andere Abteilungen, ohne dann natürlich so ins Detail zu gehen wie jetzt beim Fußball. Und wenn der Gast das aber nicht möchte, dann werde ich das auch nicht forcieren, denn das wäre ja auch komplett falsch. Also die Gäste bereiten sich eh schon wirklich außerordentlich auf den Rasenfunk vor, wie man ja immer hört. Wie jetzt nicht, dass die dann noch hektisch anfangen zu gucken, was die Tischtennis- und die Schachabteilung eigentlich so getrieben haben im letzten Jahr. Und das wäre ja dann auch nicht insofern authentisch, schwieriges Wort, aber gewinnbringend, weil wir leben von dem genuinen Interesse unserer Gäste, von ihrer Expertise und ihrer Leidenschaft. Wenn die da ist, und das ist sie im Bereich des Fußballs, deswegen laden wir sie ein, dann sind das fantastische Gäste. Und wenn die aber nicht da ist, dann passt das eigentlich auch gar nicht zu dem, was wir machen, weil eben alles, was wir tun, eben von dieser Leidenschaft für Fußball angetrieben wird. Deswegen wird es, glaube ich, weiter so sein wie bisher und dass es nicht geplant ist, aufzubrechen.
Er fragt ja auch nach eventuell einem anderen Format. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, mit dem Ziel ranzugehen, einen Verein ganzheitlich zu beleuchten, das würde tatsächlich den Rahmen springen. Und das würde auch so eine komische Erwartung bringen, dass man plötzlich über die Tiefen eines Vereines redet, wie Max sagt, was dann nur noch teilweise mit dem Fußball zu tun hat womöglich. Und was vielleicht aber wiederum auch mehr Aufgabe eines Vereins-Podcasts oder eines Club-Podcasts, wenn es auch dann ein Fußball-Podcast ist, vielleicht keine Ahnung zum 1. FC Köln, aber jetzt in der Tiefe über eine Mitgliederversammlung zu sprechen und was da in anderen Abteilungen passiert ist und so, passt sicherlich viel besser dahin. Wie aber Max sagt, wenn es im Kontext passt und wenn eben gerade Timara zum 1. FSV, MSV Mainz, FSV Köln, so geht es schon los. Zu erzählen, dann ist es natürlich super, weil es eventuell ja auch Kontext liefert zu dem, was beim Fußball passiert und so. Und weil natürlich gerade bei Bundesligavereinen der Fußball wahrscheinlich immer der massiv größte Teil des jeweiligen Clubs ist und so. Aber so als grundsätzliches Format oder Schwerpunkte darauf auszurichten, kann ich mir tatsächlich auch nicht vorstellen. Glaube ich, das würde nicht zum Rasenfunk passen. So wirklich.
Und ein letzter Gedanke noch dazu vor euch, liebe Hörer und Hörer. Die Gäste bestimmen Form und Inhalt des Rasenfunks. Und das merkt ihr manchmal auch, wenn ich zum Beispiel Gegenpositionen einnehme zum Gast. Wenn ich auf einmal ganz viel mit Statistiken um mich schmeiße und in der nächsten Sendung viel, viel weniger Statistiken von mir kommen, sondern eher andere Nachfragen. Also die Gäste lenken bewusst oder unbewusst, wie sie, also wie wir über den Verein sprechen, indem wie sie über den Verein oder das Thema sprechen, das wir im Rasenfunk haben. Und ich versuche dann, wenn ich Lücken sehe, die zu füllen, ich versuche argumentative andere Positionen aufzunehmen in meine Moderation. Gelingt natürlich mal besser, mal schlechter, aber auch das ist der Fall. Und es wurde noch nie ein Gast hier abgewirkt, wenn er gesagt hat, ich will jetzt aber noch was zu einer anderen Abteilung erzählen. Aber ich sehe es jetzt in dem Fall nicht als meine Aufgabe, dann eben nach Tischtennis zu fragen, wenn wir über Fußball in einem Fußballpodcast sprechen. Aber deswegen, die Gäste bestimmen letztlich das, was sie hier mitbringen. Und deswegen sind ja auch so viele Gäste so wahnsinnig beliebt bei euch da draußen, weil ihr dann schon so wisst, auf was man sich grob freuen kann. Nicht nur auf die Stimmen und die Kompetenz und auf die Witze, die sie mitbringen, sondern die haben ja alle so unterschiedliche Farben. Und insgesamt bildet sich dann eben das, was sich Rasenfunk nennt und jetzt schon seit elf Jahren zu hören ist. Frank, könnte man poetischer so eine Sendung zu Ende bringen?
Ja, nein, könnte man nicht. Aber ich wollte jetzt trotzdem noch ganz kurz was zu Mich-Boll sagen, weil mir an seiner Frage, mir ist gerade der Geist seiner Frage klarer geworden. Und ich glaube, wir sind ein bisschen dran vorbeigeschopft, weil wir jetzt immer Tischtennis und Badminton erwähnt haben. Er bezieht sich ja am Schluss und sagt da ja nicht nur um die Männermannschaft. Das heißt, er denkt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen an Frauen oder Jugend. Also vielleicht selbst, wenn man es beim Fußball belässt. Aber im Grunde gilt es, was Max gesagt hat, ja trotzdem. Weil wenn der Gast sich primär mit der Männermannschaft auskennt, dann macht es keinen Sinn, ihn jetzt zur Frauenmannschaft, zum Jugendbereich, was auch immer näher zu befragen. Das geht halt immer nur so weit, soweit der Gast es liefern kann. Egal ob Tischtennis, Frauenmannschaft, Jugendbereich, was auch immer. Auch Präsidium oder vereinspolitische Dinge, da kennt sich einfach nicht jeder gleich gut aus. Und wenn es Schwerpunkte sind im Bundesliga-Männerfeed, dann geht es halt nun mal schwerpunktmäßig um die Männerbundesliga. Und dann ist alles andere optional und schön, aber halt eben nicht zu erwarten.
Definitiv. Aber auch da muss man sagen, die neue Schwerpunktauslage hilft uns auch da, dass wir eben viel leichter so eine Extra-Schleife nochmal drehen können, weil nicht ein zweiter Gast darauf wartet, dass wir endlich noch über die restlichen drei Spiele des Spieltags sprechen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Absolut. Also auch dahingehend hat das geholfen.
Absolut. Und trotzdem tut es mir leid, dass ich jetzt die Poesie so gebrochen habe.
Ach, allein dafür gerechtfertigt, dass ich mich selber so gelobt habe. Das war ja total weird.
Das ist okay, das passiert ja immer viel zu selten.
Na, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber wir haben es jetzt nicht geschafft, wie Stay Forever in einer Stunde zu bleiben. Ich werde aber mal, falls euch interessiert, liebe Hörer und Hörer, sehr empfehlenswerter Gaming-Podcast, ich verlinke mal deren Folge, die ich jetzt zuletzt da gerne gehört habe. Außerdem werden natürlich in den Channels verlinkt. Also ich verlinke euch Manni und Tobi, wenn ihr euch mal gefragt habt, warum ist der Rasenfunk so schön, wie er ist. Und Steffi natürlich. Die drei sind der Grund dafür. Ihr kriegt natürlich den Link zur neuen Rasenfunk-Supporter-Seite, den ihr aber auch über rasenfunk.de leicht finden solltet. Kara auf Eis, bei TikTok, wird natürlich jetzt verlinkt. Und wenn ihr sagt, das Ganze mit der Aufteilung zwischen männlichen und weiblichen Gästen im Rasenfunk, das würde mich noch genauer interessieren. Der liebe Zaunpfahl hat es auch noch viel, viel genauer als nur so eine Gesamtzahl rausgelassen. Auch das werde ich verlinken, ist im Forum zu finden. Da könnt ihr euch das für die einzelnen Formate im Verlauf der letzten Jahre und so weiter angucken. Also wenn euch das interessiert, könnt ihr euch da noch richtig reinwöhnen. Das alles wird verlinkt und ich würde sagen, Frank, wir sagen danke, oder?
Sowieso, immer quasi. Also vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, fürs Unterstützen, fürs ins Forum kommen und da mitdiskutieren, im Discord mitdiskutieren, bei YouTube kommentieren. Wenn ihr in irgendeiner Form bei YouTube seid und uns gar nicht bei YouTube guckt, aber guckt vielleicht trotzdem mal vorbei, lasst mal ein Däumchen da, wie man das so schön sagt und macht das Plus weg und so, die ganzen modernen Dinge, die die Jugend heute so sagt.
Ich erkenne dich kaum wieder. Sehr schön. Tut das alles und dann bedanken wir uns in dieser Folge natürlich auch sehr herzlich bei einigen nach dem Zufall ausgewählten Nutzern, das in dem Fall Christopher Paul, Andre Mesut Mesi, Ostkreuzkicker Marcel und Sichtmonitor. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen und haben uns unterstützt. Schaut euch die neue Homepage an, schaut euch unsere Unterstützenseite an und empfiehlt uns sehr gerne weiter und bleibt uns auch in diesem Jahr gewogen. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, werdet oder bleibt gesund und bis bald. Ciao! Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir grüßen alle, die uns liebhaben.